Hello.
Welcome to Ghost Trick!
Hello Vtuber.
Hello.
Ghost game.
I'm Mint.
Hello, hello, hello.
Hello, hello, hello!
Welcome!
Wait, do you hear pops?
Does this sound okay?
I'm actually quite nervous.
The setup for this is new.
So hopefully it works.
I'm scared.
I'm actually a little nervous, but that's okay.
Sound okay?
Pops are a go.
Why scared?
Is it display capture?
It's actually...
Okay, so I had to...
feed my switch to my monitor.
But usually I do...
And so I capture usually from...
Or like I usually capture...
I usually play through OBS.
But since it's now directed to my monitor, instead of playing through...
Through...
What's this?
This is...
Through...
OBS.
I...
Wait, what was I saying?
I don't remember.
What was I saying?
Wait.
I would usually play through OBS.
And so the sound comes out like through my computer.
But when I put it...
Run it through my monitor, the sound was coming out through my monitor.
And I was like, wait a second.
Then you...
I won't be able to hear the game.
And you guys could hear the game.
But I wouldn't be able to hear the game.
And so I had to plug in another thing to my monitor.
But then it...
I had a lot of feedback.
It was all like...
And so I was just like, oh, how do I stop this?
And it was like two minutes before it started streaming.
And I was like, ah!
And then I was like, ah!
And then I was like, wah!
And then I fixed it.
Silly.
This suppo was sent through OBS.
No, you!
Eating Mike Tyson's ass.
Thanks for the five gifted!
Thank you.
I think I saw also...
Thank you for the 10 gifted earlier.
And Mini Scooter!
You're not up in the thingy anymore.
But I saw you earlier.
I saw you.
Thank you so much for the 50.
Thank you!
Thank you.
Let me...
I didn't know if there was going to be something that played at the very beginning.
So...
Please.
Let me know.
I think it's quiet right now.
But let me know if you can hear this.
It's so quiet.
Even for me.
Dempsey!
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
Thank you.
Thank you there.
You can hear it?
Okay.
I can still turn it up.
So...
But I don't want to...
I'm going to turn it down just a little bit.
Just because I'm scared of blowing my ears out and blowing your ears out.
So we're going to press English and we're going to see...
What happens?
What if I play Italiano?
What if I...
What if I played Italiano?
Does it need to be loud?
No.
I just want to make sure that you guys can hear it.
That's all.
Okay.
Mamma mia.
We can check...
Okay.
So...
Next.
I am playing the Switch version.
Actually, I do own the 3DS version.
I bought it before the eShop went down.
But I thought that maybe because of how 3DS captures and everything, I was worried that it might be hard to see the screens, you know, like split screen and everything.
So there's a 3DS version.
There is!
There is.
But I just bought...
I was like thinking about it earlier.
I was like, I'll play the 3DS version.
Then I thought about it.
I was like, oh, wait, maybe I should play on the Switch so you guys can...
It's best for...
On Switch for streaming.
Yeah!
I...
I don't know much about the gameplay, but I heard that you draw stuff.
So hopefully, it's not so bad on the Switch and with like a controller and not the stylus.
But it wasn't on 3DS.
It was really on DS.
Oh, really?
I thought it was a 3DS game.
Oh, oh, oh.
But yeah, so I'm playing it.
If you're curious, I am playing it on the Switch.
Auto saves.
Okay.
Yeah!
Welcome!
To Ghost Train!
Oh my gosh!
Saku!
Why?
Thank you for the 50!
Thank you.
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh my gosh.
Saku!
There's already extras.
I'm curious.
But...
Time to flex your detective skills.
Oh!
You silly little wispy you.
I happen to be...
Stupid.
New game!
I got a small raise.
Membooships for everyone.
Congrats!
Chapter 1.
Oh!
And 7.02pm.
Actually, it's 7.17pm.
Is my Switch clock off?
Must have been unconscious for a while.
My head feels fuzzy.
Kind of like I'm swimming through darkness.
Oh my gosh.
When I came to, there was a woman standing there.
A woman I don't know.
At least, I don't think I know her.
Okay.
The text is kind of fast.
Oh!
A dashing man.
And then there was a man with a gun.
I don't know him either.
Well, probably not anyway.
Oh, wait.
Is that...
A skull?
A skull face?
Oh, no.
He has got a big nose.
Nevermind.
Oh!
Hands up!
Now, I'm not the kind of guy who can just stand back and watch a poor woman get shot.
But I have just one little problem.
Oh!
My ass is up!
I'm already dead myself!
Oh!
This has got to be me.
No question about that.
After all, do you see any other dead bodies lying around here?
Pew!
Hands up!
Hands where I can see them.
So...
Sister!
I feel bad for her.
Sure.
But what can I do?
I'm dead!
Just as I was thinking this.
So relatable.
There is no time to be lollying around dead.
You're the only one who can save her.
Me?
But I'm dead!
What the?
The whole world just changed on me.
Oh, now I can press.
Oh, okay.
Are you sure about that, boss?
What do you mean?
Look!
It's you!
That's you!
Right there!
Oh my gosh!
That's you!
Point!
That's you right there!
That's you!
I'm in the game!
Welcome to the Ghost World.
The land of the dead!
Oh my gosh!
Oh my gosh, you came here to see me, didn't you?
If Mint misses a Super Chat, did they get ghosted?
No?
I didn't miss any, did I?
Such an undignified position.
Look ma'am, famous.
A voice in my head?
Who are you?
No time for introductions now.
You have to save her.
You know you can do it.
All you have to do is use your powers.
Huh?
Me to save her?
How?
There I am, Gary.
There I am.
Am I the narrator?
Me?
Mint?
The narrator?
I like that.
No,
you are dead.
Stop, sorry.
Welcome to the ghost world.
A world covered in ghosts.
Enjoy the world of ghosts.
Yippee!
Take a look at your corpse.
Do you see that blue flame?
That's your soul.
And do you see that bright white spot nearby?
That's a core.
A core?
Hmm, looks like a railway crossing gate to me.
Look, the best way to understand it is just try it.
First of all, try moving your soul with the D-pad.
Can I move with... oh, whoa!
Oh!
That was so easy.
I'm a natural.
Obviously.
Congratulations!
Your soul is now possessed the crossing gate.
So, what?
Now I'm a crossing gate?
Ahem.
Now then, use the crossing gate to save the woman.
Oh my gosh, I'm gonna beat him over the head.
But how?
In a moment...
In a moment, time will start to flow normally again.
That will be your chance.
Listen, when the man pulls the trigger, the woman dies, right?
So before that happens, you have to use your powers to stop...
Oh gosh, is this game timed?
Oh boy.
Hey, wait a second!
I still don't know what you're talking about!
You'll see.
You'll all see.
Now then, time will start to flow again.
Raise!
Oh!
Oof!
Ouchie, ouch!
Hold it!
How ace attorney of you.
Well played.
What just happened?
That was one of your powers at work.
A ghost trick!
You mean I made that crossing gate move?
That's right.
You manipulated that object with the power of the dead.
A ghost trick!
Yeah, cue the credits!
All you have to do to perform a trick like that is press A.
Now the woman's fate has changed.
Albeit, just a little.
Yeah, she still has... she still kind of has a gun pointed at her.
Yes.
Hmm.
That's not good, is it?
But at least now you're starting to figure out how to use your powers.
So I enter the ghost world with ghost.
I... I go... I'm... I'm ghost!
I'm gonna ghost all over the place!
Wait, let me put my hand down actually, now that I think about it.
Blasphemy, I know, but...
Just so you guys can see a bit better.
I'm gonna ghost all over the place!
Possess an object and then perform a trick with it, eh?
Bust in, bust in, bust in...
Now you're getting it!
Let's move on to the next step.
Try possessing a different core.
Okay.
Do I have a guitar?
I see, a guitar then, is it?
Ahem.
Wait, no, I was just moving!
What do you want from me?
I would have preferred that giant wrecking ball.
That would solve the problem real quick, I bet.
But I guess I can't reach cores that are too far away.
It's right there, it's not that far.
Well, I guess we'll see what you can do with that guitar.
Let's set time and motion again and find out.
Oh, am I gonna fail the tutorial?
Uh...
Who's there?
Ouch!
Oh, nice!
Hold it!
That's gotta be some of the slowest running away I've ever seen.
Oh, you couldn't reach for the wrecking ball, it's too far.
Got it.
Looks like I'm gonna have to come up with something more.
I can possess my dead body?
What core is close enough to possess from here?
I guess all there is, is me.
No time to be picky, I've got a woman to save!
I like your attitude.
It's admirable, truly, but...
But what?
If I can manipulate objects, I can manipulate my own body!
Hahaha!
Then I ought to be able to manipulate my own corpse, right?
Well, tell you what.
Why don't you just try it and see?
Go ahead and possess your corpse.
Okay.
Alright then.
Uh, now we'll set time and motion.
Go ahead and try A.
Is this gonna be really freaky?
Oh.
Nothing's happening.
Exactly.
Sad but true, I'm afraid.
You can only manipulate non-living things.
Um, I'm non-living!
Clearly!
Corpses, even though they are...
Oh my gosh.
Daniel!
Thank you for the...
Akasuma!
Hope you enjoy the game.
That's one of my all-time faves.
Much love, Minto.
Thank you!
Corpses, even if they aren't alive anymore, aren't really just ordinary things.
You've gotta be kidding!
This music is so Ace Attorney.
Wait.
What about the woman?
What's happening to her?
Let's take a look, shall we?
If you wanna take a look around, you can move the screen.
Oh.
Move the screen?
Um.
I don't know what you mean by that.
Mysterious voice?
Uh, what is this?
Some kind of video game?
It's easy.
Give it a try.
Use the D-pad to move it in any direction you want.
Ooh.
Wow.
That was nice.
I love this game.
Hope you'll like it too.
Thanks!
Whenever you wanna see what's going on somewhere, just move the screen.
Okay.
I got it.
Minto, turn off the game console.
Right now, I wanna see what's happening to that woman.
Of course.
Well, you know what to do, then.
Move the screen and see if you can find her.
There she is.
Well, sister.
This is it.
Press Alt-F.
F4.
You have to plug the controller into Port 4.
Two things are looking pretty dim right now.
My eyesight and your future!
No way!
She's dead!
Oh.
I didn't strum hard enough.
Ring-a-ling-a-ling.
The graphics in this look...
Is this a...
Is this like a remake?
I don't know.
Out of my way!
Oh my god!
Oh, it is a remake.
It looks so good.
Or remaster.
Yeah.
Because it was a DS game, right?
So...
Oh my god.
Wait, someone, please pick up the phone!
It's done.
On my way.
Oh, and...
Whoa!
We look so cool.
Oh.
What was that?
Did he bow at me?
In the end, it looks like her fate remains unchanged.
So what good are these ghost tricks of mine?
But just as I was thinking this...
Oop!
This lamp came...
Oh my gosh!
The Pixar lamp!
No way!
I'm talking to a lamp!
Oh no, my delusions are really acting up today.
Oh my god.
Hello there.
How are you feeling?
Not very well, I imagine.
A terrible tragedy, what happened tonight.
Pixar real?
Ah, ignoring me, are you?
It's a little too early for you to be so stiff and cold, I'd say.
I love lamp.
So it was you.
You were that voice in my head, right?
Well, I wouldn't say voice, exactly.
The dead don't have voices, you see.
It's more...
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Was the Pixar lamp murdered?
I don't know.
It's more like my thoughts were being beamed directly into your mind.
That's another little trick ghosts can do.
Yeah.
I can do that, obviously.
I do that to you guys all the time.
Any time you think about mint, it's me beaming into your mind.
Think about mint.
Kushaaa.
Wow.
Just like that.
Let me read your mind.
Psycho Mintus.
It worked!
Hello Mint-ko-san.
You are cool.
Thank you!
Thanks for the super chat!
Looks like my ghost tricks didn't do much good.
Oh, rip.
Actual rip.
She still ended up just as dead as before.
How do I suddenly have mint choco ice in my hand?
That's true.
For now.
For now?
I still have more to teach you about the powers of the dead.
Your ghost tricks.
Who exactly are you anyway?
One of your fans.
Before I answer that, I think we should save this video.
Wait, how do we do that?
Isn't it a shame to see such a pretty young woman lying here like a discarded piece of trash?
Did I get give mint all your money beamed right into my head right now?
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you.
The name's Pixar.
Disney Pixar.
But what can I do?
She's already dead.
Is she?
Time for more ghost lessons for you, my friend.
First of all, I'll have you possess me.
Possess you, eh?
Once you've done that, I'll tell you about another one of your powers.
I like the lighting in this.
Why am I so determined to save this woman?
After all, it's not like I know her.
But I guess I'll take the desk lamp up on his invitation anyway.
My reason is twofold.
I mean, what else do we have to do, right?
Number one, I'm not the type to leave women lying around this garden like trash.
Good job, ghost trick.
Mr. Ghost Trick.
And number two, I don't have anything else to lose at this point.
So true.
That's how I feel.
Trick time!
Uh, what is this?
X?
That thought bubble you just pressed.
Those are your thoughts.
What you're saying to yourself in your head.
No, I'm thinking?
Ah!
Ow!
My thoughts, eh?
So the dead don't have voices.
Men to my head told me to do this or she'd beat me up.
And what we think is communicated directly to one another.
So these thought bubbles are sort of a stand-in.
I think I'm starting to get it.
John Ghost Trick respects women.
Be like John.
Thank you for the super chat, you guys.
I think so too.
Just remember to always keep an eye out for thought bubbles.
Okay, good idea.
I might... I just might get some important clues from them.
Now then.
Possess me!
In order to possess me, you first have to enter the ghost world.
And L is your ticket in.
Oh my gosh, I'm ghosting, I'm ghosting.
The best thing to do is to try it.
LA?
Guess I'll press it.
I'm ghosting!
Door...
Traffic sign...
Oh, by the way, have you taken a look at the middle of the screen?
What about it?
It tells you what trick you can perform with the object you're currently possessing.
What does that mean if I put a mint in my mouth?
Oh, if it put a mint in my mouth.
Means brush your teeth more.
Don't forget to floss.
The information is there for you to check out whenever you need it.
So in the case of this folding cot, it looks like I can unfold it.
And to perform a trick on the object you're possessing, you first have to return to the land of the living.
Oh, okay.
This time B is your ticket out of the ghost world.
Well, good luck.
We're counting on you.
Who is this wii?
Flag...
Take me to dinner first.
Oh, I can't reach the phone.
I'm a weak...
Wait, how do I get to the...
How do I...
Oh, so I have to figure out a way to...
Maybe if I un...
If I unfold it, maybe I can...
Trick.
There we go.
Now I'm closer.
Now I'm gonna ghost again.
Wait, what's that up there?
She's getting it.
Use the fan?
No, I got it.
I got it perfectly.
That's funny.
What is?
What's so funny?
She's a different color.
My corpse and her corpse.
There's definitely something different about the two.
There's something emanating from my corpse.
That's because...
You're dead!
Oh, I'm special.
I'm special.
What's that supposed to mean?
Not everybody who dies gets special powers, you know.
So those waves are because of my powers of the dead.
The smell of decay.
That's my stench wafting the dead smell.
Anyway.
Congratulations.
You passed.
Well, what do you know?
What prize do I get?
A new power.
What else?
Another one?
Now let's review.
You can possess objects and manipulate them, right?
Now what do you suppose will happen if you possess a corpse?
Nothing, because I already tried that, remember?
Nothing happened at all.
True.
You don't have the ability to manipulate a corpse.
But...
But?
I think it's kind of...
I don't even know her and I'm already, like, possessing her body?
Like...
And she's...
I mean, she's...
I...
She's, like, so beautiful.
I just...
He called her sister.
I mean, that doesn't mean we're related, right?
What if we're just a family?
Am I possessing my sister?
Help me, step bro.
I'm dead.
However, there's something else you can do.
Oh, yeah?
What's that?
Why don't you try it and see?
Oh, okay.
I would like a little bit of a warning, what I'm about to do.
I'm go...
I'm going ghost!
Oh, whoa.
What is that?
What's...
What's this?
Baby corn.
Thanks for the five.
Gifted.
Thank you.
Can you hear me?
It's you guys.
Wait a minute.
What's going on here?
Hmm.
Looks like she's unconscious.
Poor thing.
Unconscious?
But she's dead.
I don't know...
I know you don't like spicy food, but any chance of a Hot Ones podcast with Tara?
That's so funny you brought that up.
Robert?
I don't remember because I literally watched the Hot Ones...
I don't know.
Do you call them episodes?
The Hot Ones video with Conan O'Brien earlier.
I love that guy.
He's so funny.
He's so crazy.
But think back.
Remember when you died?
He just started chugging it.
Yeah.
He's so unhinged.
It was the best episode.
It's so good.
If you haven't watched it...
I don't know.
Even if you don't know anything about Conan O'Brien, I think that episode will teach you everything you need to know about that guy.
When you came to your senses, you'd been unconscious too.
Unconscious, eh?
Mint, please wake up.
I'm alive.
I'm...
No, I'm not alive.
I'm awake.
Come to think of it, the desk lamp is right.
When I came to, I was already dead.
How long had I been ass up there?
How long did they leave me like that?
Let's leave her like this for now.
And while she's resting, we can save her life.
Oh, sure.
You make it sound so easy.
And it is easy.
When you use your powers on a corpse, you can go back to the past to a time four minutes before that person's dead.
Are you serious?
Back through time?
My new dream collab is Mint and Conan O'Brien.
Okay.
I'll do my best to have a collab with Conan O'Brien.
Someday.
That's right, but there's a catch.
It only works on new corpses.
Corpses that have been dead for less than one day.
Then why didn't you do that on my body, huh?
And she's still wet.
So, well...
Fuck.
Sorry.
I was thinking, like, a fresh...
I was thinking, like, a fresh body.
Like, you know how...
Like, when you...
Okay.
When I think of, like, a fresh body, it's, like, meaty and wet.
You know what I mean?
So...
Girl.
She's still well within that limit.
Okay, you...
Okay.
I know what happened.
The T from the limit...
What?
Went up, and it...
I didn't...
I just...
I only saw T...
I read too quickly, okay?
She's moist.
Oh...
Oh, no.
You've been holding out on us.
We knew you were a cute ghost maid, but we didn't know you also had a cute time traveling ghost maid.
I don't know...
I don't know if I have that powers.
You might want to give it a try before it's too late.
Oh, no...
But this is crazy!
None of it makes any sense!
We're talking about the powers of the dead here.
It doesn't have to make sense.
Now then, let's go, shall we?
To the time four minutes before this woman was murdered!
Hey, wait a second!
I still don't know what you're talking about!
You'll see.
Rewind time.
Ghosts only haunt wet corpses taking over.
Freshly moist.
We can't have the decay, you know?
So now I'm going back in time to witness this woman's last four minutes alive.
Not as a fuzzy distant memory of the past, but as a very real living present.
Four minutes before death.
Oh my gosh!
This music is so Ace Attorney.
Can you imagine?
Imagine if we, like, go back four minutes in time.
And, like, some person was just like, Woohoo!
Like somewhere, somewhere totally unrelated across the other side of the world.
They were like, I just won the jackpot!
The lottery!
But because we went back four minutes in time, and we're doing some butterfly effect.
For some, something is changing.
Where the guy is gonna, like, drop his ticket instead and just loses everything.
That'd be so sad!
Time paradox.
Wake up!
Are you okay?
What happened to you?
Oh no!
He's...dead!
Don't say it like it's a bad thing.
Mint Mike's da closet collab.
I can't, he's my Oshii.
I'm too scared to collab with Oshii's.
Who are you?
Cucumber!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
I'm Skull Face.
This is brother.
Here's my business card right here, sister.
My little gold...oh!
My little golden friend.
You did this.
You killed him, didn't you?
Instead of playing whodunit right now, you ought to be more concerned about your own fate.
Who is she?
Who is he?
Why are we here?
I have so many questions.
Who are you?
Some sort of a hitman?
What do you want with me?
They said we had to rub out all the last traces of Temsik left in this country.
Temsik?
What in the world is that?
It's me.
I just do what I...
How are you supposed to wipe out what you don't even know what it is?
All I know is you've got nowhere else to run to.
Time to die, sister.
Oh!
Oh, as long as that bad boy Wrecking Ball...
I sure hope this Wrecking Ball doesn't fall on my head and crush me.
That would be so bad.
As long as that bad boy Wrecking Ball stays right up there where it belongs.
Look, all I want to know is who are you?
You don't know me.
And I don't know you.
This is just business.
He's so cool.
So long, sister.
Oh!
Nice!
Oof!
Hold it!
Who's there?
Wait...
This is all that what we did before, but...
Hold it!
Shotgun?
What kind of a flashy weapon for a hitman don't...
Oh, kind of a flashy weapon for a hitman, don't you think?
Too shy to collab with Oshis, ma'am.
You did the exact thing the other day.
I know!
And look how it turned out!
Not flashy, just thorough.
They call me Nearsighted Jigo.
But I never let my prey get away.
Get this man some glasses.
Never thought about just buying a pair of glasses.
Well, sister.
This is it.
Oh my god.
No way.
That's her last words.
Two things are looking pretty dim right now.
My eyesight?
Oh!
That's why he said his eyesight.
I love Nearsighted Jigo.
And there you have it.
The last four minutes of her life.
No!
It's kind of ironic when you think about it.
A woman toyed with by fate and a man toyed with by a ghost.
But she still died.
Yes.
And you can change that with your ghost tricks.
Just like you did four minutes ago.
Possess and manipulate, eh?
Ghost and then trick.
Man, they love title dropping.
They love it.
How is that ironic?
It's like rain on your wedding day.
It's the green...
Wait.
It's the...
It's the sun...
It's...
The light...
When you're already late.
Wait.
Green light?
Does that...
How does that make any sense?
Oh!
Free ride when you already paid.
Doesn't they say something when you're late?
Oh.
It's the good advice that you just didn't take.
And who would have thought it mattered?
You can rewind these four minutes as many times as you like, too.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm going to keep watching this lady die.
Yeah.
Drama.
Now, then.
Are you ready?
Yeah.
Let's do it.
My soul hurts with all the straw things.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh.
Okay.
All right.
Soul.
So, this is four minutes ago, eh?
Fine.
I get that.
What am I doing way down here?
That's just how it works.
Her corpse was your gateway into the past after all.
So, naturally, your starting point is where her corpse was.
This is where she died.
Okay.
I get it now.
My favorite show.
Lady dies on loop.
Oh.
Oh, my gosh.
It's not...
It's basically ReZero.
Hop in, then.
I'm ghosting.
Okay.
I'm in.
Oh, my God.
The time is going down.
Okay.
Good job.
There are only four minutes left before she dies.
You had better try and get to her as fast as you can.
There's no time to lose.
Who are you?
Oh.
They're already...
Oh, my gosh.
She's already meeting him.
Let me play.
Oh, my gosh.
Time is passing.
The last seconds of her life are counting down.
Looks like I better get up there fast.
That's right.
Have a look at the right side of the screen.
The right side?
Oh, yes.
The sand meter.
Okay.
The sand in the top of that timer is how much time she has left.
Get to her quickly before all the sand is gone.
Up you go, then.
I'm going ghost.
Oh, wait.
Oh, my gosh.
Why did you make me go up?
No.
I'm going this way.
Wait.
Trick?
Okay.
Nice.
Ghost.
Up.
Can I turn this on?
And then maybe it will blow the flag so we can go up even higher.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
Wait a second.
Oh.
Turn off.
Oh, okay.
I think I have to be faster.
I think I have to...
Okay.
Hold on.
I think I have to turn it on.
Trick.
And then ghost.
And then go.
Okay.
There we go.
And then back.
All right.
Lift me up.
And then...
Oh, no.
I can't reach.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Am I trapped now?
You guys.
I think I...
Not back seating but she dunked.
I think I messed up.
Oh.
Thank goodness.
Oh, my gosh.
I knew that I dunked.
Wait.
How do I get up there then?
She overcooked.
Did I overcook?
Okay.
Trunk.
Trick.
Can I go up there?
Ghost.
Oh, this rolls!
Okay, I missed that.
Trick!
Nice.
Open.
I had an idea of something.
Oh my god.
Who are you?
Some sort of a hitman?
What do you want with me?
They said that we had to... Come on, come on, come on.
Time is passing.
Her time is running out.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
Close.
The mannequin to this.
But what?
What will this... Turn on.
Ah, I see, I see, I see, I see.
So that will... Maybe it will catch on to the rope and then...
And then it will rise me up?
Maybe?
There we go.
Oh my gosh.
So long, sister.
Just a few more steps.
Hope I may make it in time.
Time is passing!
Oh my gosh.
Wait, there's so much time left though.
Stop stressing me out, game.
She's cooking.
So I had the right idea earlier.
I know what to do.
Oof.
Oh, oofie oof.
Hold it.
No, no, we want him to stand under the ball!
Now's your chance to change your fate!
There isn't much time left.
This is coming down to a battle of seconds!
Trick time.
I'm... uh...
Till death... wait... uh...
Ring the bell... or pedal?
Pedal to the metal... ring the bell...
Hmm...
He didn't like the... the guitar startled him before, so let's try ringing.
What's going on here?
Nearsighted Jigo never misses, as long as the target is within point blank range.
Run far away!
Uh...
It looks like you made it in time.
Just barely.
Yep, she's still alive!
Bro, get glasses for real!
And in that split second, hope was born.
Just now her fate was changed, albeit ever so slightly.
Yippee!
Oh, oh no, her leg.
Oh, you gotta be kidding me!
The bridge is up!
Uh-oh.
Trick time!
Uh...
Pedal?
Can I... oh wait, X...
You said her fate was changed.
Hyper Miracle...
Positive girl!
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
But it looks like she's still in the same predicament.
I said her fate was changed ever so slightly.
What is this junkyard drawbridge?
Right?
Do they have a moat or something?
Hold on, I'm gonna take a bite of my food.
I have some chicken... and rice.
Guess I'm gonna have to take care of that guy once and for all.
But there isn't much time left, depending on what you do.
There is still the possibility of failure.
You're so good at being a ghost, what's your secret?
A laundry list.
I don't want to think about failure now.
No, of course not.
But still...
If you ever feel like you want to start over...
Just tap R before time runs out.
Although you may never know...
You might learn a thing or two when time runs out too.
Ooh...
Alright, I'll keep that in mind.
But right now, I better go after those two.
Oh
no, there was a bubble!
My bad.
I got so excited.
You hear something?
No?
That'd be like crazy.
He's under it again.
Oh yeah, he is.
We can extend the ladder.
Oh, I can't wait to get this...
Oh my gosh, I'm so excited for these to get like super complicated.
I'm not gonna lie.
I came in like a wreck.
How does it feel to save a lady's life?
I killed someone else in the process!
Oh my god, now he's gonna haunt me.
So the danger is gone?
Yes, it looks like the danger...
Mr. Danger, in fact, rolled away somewhere.
He got Looney Tooned.
Yahoi!
You used your powers to avert that woman's fate.
What if she is like a really bad person?
What if she like...
Created a drug that's gonna turn everybody...
The whole world into zombies and we just...
That guy was trying to prevent that.
And we...
We just...
We just doomed the whole world.
If bad, why cute?
So true, though.
Don't you know Nearsighted Jigo?
He's...
He's a cut boss fight from Metal Gear 1 for the MSX.
It does sound like...
His name does sound like that.
It could be though, right?
Mint is the danger.
No!
What are you talking about?
So I did all that, huh?
You most certainly did.
And I knew you could do it.
Fate averted!
Woohoo!
So I lost my life tonight.
And saved somebody else's life.
Yippee!
When I came back to the present...
It was raining.
Oh my gosh.
Am I gonna be her ghost boyfriend?
I had saved the life of this stranger.
Now sitting forlornly in the rain.
Aww.
Even as the story of my life on this planet comes to an end.
Achoo!
Bless you.
Oh no.
A stranger.
That word strikes a chord.
And a terrible truth begins to dawn on me.
She could be the bad guy?
I can't recall a thing.
Tasukaru.
So cute.
Who am I?
What is this place?
The most important...
Impa...
Clearly not important if I can't even say it.
Most important of all.
Why was I killed?
I wonder that every day.
Your story isn't over yet.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Is this gonna end with us like...
Moving on?
And...
You know...
That's so sad.
Who exactly are you anyway?
Just call me Ray.
As in...
Ray of light in the darkness.
Ray, huh?
No way.
Metal Gear Ray.
No spoilers.
Yeah.
This is my first time playing this game, so...
Oh, I should have written that, right?
Oh.
There's something really...
That I...
Here.
I came up with this idea.
If you ever see spoilers in the chat...
Like maybe someone posts something...
That's just like...
Alluding to something.
Um...
Or...
Just to...
Just a straight up spoiler...
Uh...
Use...
Smiley faces...
To get...
To push it...
Off...
Of the...
Screen.
But...
So that way I don't read it.
If I'm like cooking...
And I maybe think of something...
Don't use smiley faces.
Because I don't think I'm correct.
I'll be like...
Maybe I'm onto something.
You know what I mean?
Well, that's a new and novel idea, right?
Isn't it kind of genius?
I'm kind of...
No one else has ever thought of that.
Ever...
I'm a genius.
Frowning for cooking.
Ray, huh?
So you aren't going to tell me your real name.
I take it.
You haven't told me your name yet.
Actually...
I'm Mr. Trick.
I'm Mr. Ghost Trick.
I can't remember.
Yes, I guess the memory is of the newly departed...
No, I'm Minto!
Minto cute.
That's the worst spoiler of them all.
And that is... to disappear.
Disappear?
Ban that guy.
I understand...
I understand the issue.
I understand the intent.
But other people might get confused too.
And I'd rather...
I don't know.
I don't want anything fake spoilers.
Unless it's overly jokey.
We'll just not do any spoilers at all.
Minto is actually Patrick Swayze.
Oh my darling.
I long for your touch.
Pottery...
I'd like to use them to save somebody else's life.
And who's life might that be?
I don't know.
Grandma?
She's gonna cross the street.
Doesn't realize a truck is coming.
Minto's secretly big bull.
But errr... dies off screen.
Do you even have to ask?
Mine, of course.
I see.
Thank you!
I'm actually a lamp.
A ray of lightmack.
A of lightmack!
Oh my gosh.
Metal gear ray of lightmack.
But think about it this way.
If we could use ghost tricks to save ourselves...
Wouldn't I have tried to save myself as well?
I mean, look at me.
I'm a desk lamp.
But also...
Why didn't you disappear?
Can we save the desk lamp then?
Because...
If the desk lamp is still here...
Why doesn't...
Why haven't we...
Wait...
How long have they been around for?
I was only half heart at least.
Spoiler?
Okay.
No, stop.
Why a desk lamp anyway?
I'm not really sure myself to be honest.
But in any case, it seems we are unable to use our powers on our own corpses.
Time to go find our little desk friend.
You're kidding!
You'll only exist in this world until tomorrow morning.
How do you even know that?
I'm afraid that fact can't be changed.
So there's really no escaping my own death?
Okay, desk lamp.
Why also did you not try to save me?
In the morning, I'm going to cease to exist.
Apparently, there's nothing I can do to change that.
But just the same, I still want to know...
I want to know my story.
The lost story of my fate.
Right up until the time of my death.
Until I learn that.
You won't be able to rest in peace, right?
Yeah.
Very well.
I understand how you feel.
You want to go and learn the truth about your death.
As well, you should.
I will.
But let's see.
How should I go about doing that, I wonder?
Can't even imagine what the first step would be.
The first step?
That's easy.
You start with her!
Sneeze!
I predicted the future.
The person who witnessed your death.
She should have some important clues, don't you think?
She's so cute.
Hey, you're right.
Not only that...
She might even know who I am!
Tasukaru.
Yes, I'd say there's a very good possibility of that.
What was I doing here tonight in a place like this?
That woman probably knows the answer.
Hi, Minto.
Hello!
That's right.
Never forget that.
She is the key to everything tonight.
The key to everything?
What do you mean?
You'll know soon enough when you regain your memory.
Yeah, I'm like a baby.
I'm like a newborn baby.
I'm like a blank sheet of paper right now.
I should probably keep some sort of record of everything I learned tonight.
That's a very good idea.
Press ZL to view a record of what you've learned.
And be sure to check it out now and then.
Okay.
Memories aren't always the most reliable things after all.
My court record.
Phone book.
Alright then, I wish you good luck.
Trick time.
So if we go to our...
Me.
The mystery.
Red-headed target.
Oh no.
Come on.
Why would you mute her sneeze?
Ray of light.
Hunter in the dark.
He calls himself Nearsighted Jigo.
But he's gone now due to an unfortunate accident.
I kind of miss him, not gonna lie.
I lost my life at a lonely spot on the outskirts of town.
What?
Yeah, an accident.
Saved her with my powers of the dead.
He taught me the secrets.
Okay.
I'm going ghost!
If I trick...
I better not let her out of my sight.
Besides, I'm not the kind of guy who can just let a woman sit sneezing in the cold rain.
I think I'll try to move closer.
Yeah, yeah.
That's what I'm trying to do.
Yes.
Oh, shimmy.
Shimmy, shimmy.
There we go.
Shimmy.
She's still sneezing!
Wait, how can I...
There she is.
She's just...
She's still sneezing in the rain.
Trying to get closer to him.
Yeah.
I'm going ghost.
Oh!
We can give her the umbrella!
That's so cute!
Oh it's a miracle.
What in the world just happened?
The crane moved all by itself, and then that big iron ball fell all by itself?
It started raining... wait, that's just how the weather goes.
That's just how the weather works.
It started raining all by itself, and then an umbrella came down all by itself?
Oh my goodness.
Don't tell me I have psychokinetic powers!
Yes.
You are the chosen one.
You guys, I almost bought Arona's...
Someone was selling Arona's umbrella on Mercari.
And it was really expensive, so I didn't buy it, but I thought about it.
I was like, I should buy this.
It's expensive, but it's cool.
A cat!
Best game... oh, best game ever!
Oh!
Okay.
Disrespect my body like that.
My Lupin looking ass.
But then it sold out, and I was so sad.
Oh, um... looks like she's saying something to herself.
Unfortunately, I can't hear from here.
Oh!
That's no problem for a ghost like us, as long as your target's not too far away.
Just like you do with your own thought bubbles.
If you tap the thought bubbles of the living, you can listen in on them, what they're saying.
Maybe I'll just take a little listen then.
Always watch for the thought bubbles of the living.
They might give you some important clues.
Interesting.
Seriously, what in the world just happened?
It's me!
Oh!
What's this?
Some kind of note.
Okay.
I want to see that note.
I wonder what I wrote on it.
It's not just a shopping list or something.
Or hopefully it's not just a shopping list.
That wouldn't help.
Should I check it out?
Okay, cool!
Examine.
I am now the note.
Did I write this note?
Maybe I should give it a read.
By beating Nearsighted Jigo, you got card key 1!
Now you enter the base, Outer YouTube, and destroy Metal Gear Algorithm.
So you don't remember writing it, eh?
No, I don't remember writing it.
But even more importantly...
Uh-oh.
Don't answer it.
No, no, no!
Why would you do that?
Hello?
I didn't get a chance to read the note!
Not to interrupt your train of thought, but...
I wonder if he realized where this telephone call is coming from?
How would I know that?
Think back.
Before you helped to revert her fate.
Didn't a telephone call come in around at this time too?
Oh yeah!
No!
Oh my god, he's so cool.
Going down the stairs.
It's done.
I'm on my way.
No!
That telephone call!
Exactly.
In other words, at this very moment...
on the other end of this telephone line...
is the culprit who ordered your murder!
What?
Um...
I'll take a pizza...
or cheese...
I recommend you possess the telephone.
Once you've done that, I'll tell you about another one of your ghost tricks.
Oh my gosh.
Trick time!
I'm going ghost.
I'm possessing.
And then I saw him.
Right there on the other end of the line.
He ordered me dead!
Oh my gosh, I'm so excited.
What does he look like?
He's probably so cool.
He's probably so mysterious.
No!
I got killed by grandpa.
Is it done?
Look at this...
Look at this tiny guy!
His oversized notebook and everything.
He's got so many pictures of himself.
Speak up, man.
Did you get her?
Yes.
Who is...
Who is this?
Yes.
A thousand pardons, my dear lady.
I must have dialed the wrong number.
Trace complete.
So that's him, eh?
The man who stole my life!
We don't know that yet though, right?
Bet the note says she did it.
Probably, right?
Hold on, I'm gonna have another bite of food.
I have to like pick up the plate.
And like move it over.
And then...
Put it back.
Because I don't have much room on my desk.
Yum yum.
Mogu mogu.
No, this guy was after her.
We don't know if he was after you.
That's right.
So what do you think?
Would you like to go see him?
You better believe I would.
Then you would do well to listen to me.
We ghosts exist by possessing inanimate objects.
However...
There is one way we can move from place to place over great distances.
Through the phone.
The internet.
Oh my gosh.
Become a digital ghost.
Become a Vtuber ghost.
Me.
And that would be...
The dead can jump from point A to point B.
By moving over phone lines.
Say woo!
I've done all I can do to help you.
You'll have to do the rest yourself.
No!
No Ray!
Don't leave!
You're not coming with me?
I'm afraid not.
I've grown weak.
I've already used up most of my remaining strength just to get here tonight.
But why?
Why are you here?
How do you know me?
But I had to come to ask for your help.
Always wanted to play this game but...
It's on my ever growing backlog.
So I'm happy to see you play it.
Thanks Kinky!
Hope you like it.
Me too.
Let's have fun together.
My help?
Many mysterious things will happen in this town tonight.
I'm trusting in you to get to the bottom of them.
And find out the truth.
You're the only one who can do it!
I want you to use your powers of the dead to find this truth!
I'm grateful to you.
For everything you've done.
Lampy.
But I can't promise I'll help.
Tomorrow morning I cease to exist.
That doesn't give me a whole lot of time.
I need to pursue my own mystery.
Find out the truth about myself.
That's more than enough.
Huh?
If you succeed in doing that.
You'll have done what I asked anyway.
The two are one and the same.
One and the same?
Let's get you to 200,000 subs mint!
Hashtag winning ghost.
Thank you!
Yeah!
I'll do my best!
This desk lamp knows a whole lot more than he's telling me.
Now then.
From what I call a moment ago.
You have the culprit's telephone number.
The rest is all up to you.
We're going here.
SYS 1729.
Here we go!
Nice.
And so the story of the search for myself begins.
A story that will last one night only.
Tomorrow morning I will cease to exist.
And I'm surprisingly okay with this fact.
I have to...
I have to find the answers before the sun comes up.
Why was I killed?
And what exactly is going on to happen...
going to happen in this town tonight?
We have to haunt Dr. Weird's blue cousin.
Oh!
Illustrations.
Cleared 7.02 to 7.31 pm.
Music?
Four minutes before death?
Oh my gosh!
Look at him!
Sure.
We'll save.
Save.
Yes.
Continue playing.
How long have I been?
An hour to get through the tutorial, guys.
Let's go!
7.31 pm.
Who am I?
Why was I killed?
The one who is sure to know the answers to those questions is the man who ordered my murder.
At the other end of the phone line is the very man who had me killed.
Our meeting.
It's all so sudden.
Who is that massive guy on the right?
A Mr. X?
I'm not sure I'm really prepared for what's to come.
Me neither!
Hmm.
Yes.
If what I read in this file is true, this woman could be quite a bedeviling bit of trouble for us.
She needs to be erased.
Tonight.
Confound that nearsighted Jigo.
His skills are as feeble as his eyesight.
Not to worry, sir.
I have already taken the next steps, sir.
Beep, beep, beep, beep.
Oh my gosh.
Whoa!
He's hacking!
Oh my god, they have her three sizes and everything!
Hmm.
Yes.
Would I say the last thing I ever expected was to talk to the target herself.
Even if it was only over the telephone.
I must admit to my guard I'm a good man.
It put me in quite the tizzy there for a moment.
What is this place?
These oddly luxurious furnishings.
This oddly refined music.
Oh no, the music's diegetic.
And that odd little machine.
I've never seen a room like this before.
But one...
They got her 3D debut.
Yeah!
One thing's for sure.
These people are assassins.
And what's more, they're blue!
Oh, the red-headed woman is another one of their targets.
Strider, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
That file the old man has.
Maybe it'll give me some information on my red...
My red head?
Trick time!
I'm going ghost!
What's this thing?
I can't reach it.
Time to examine.
Girl looks like a rooster.
Stop!
A very cute rooster.
Like the cutest rooster.
Seems this file contains information about that red head.
But I can't read it when it's closed.
Oh, thank you.
Great Scott!
Did you see that?
The file, I say!
Wait, what voice did I have for this guy?
I can't remember.
It sounds like maybe he's British.
Wait...
The file reared up and snapped at me, my good man.
Nearly bit my head off.
Not to worry, sir.
I've already seen to it that the target Miss...
Miss Lynn!
Is no longer a threat, sir.
It's my darkness!
Bah!
That's not what I'm talking about, man!
Glasses out for nearsighted Jiro.
Hmm, Lynn, eh?
So that's her name, is it?
But this file...
It's like it's written in a foreign language.
Oh no, we forgot how to read!
I can't read it at all!
Might I suggest putting away the file and relaxing, sir?
Beep, beep, beep!
We're gonna watch VTubers!
Oh!
Whoa!
This place is so fancy!
Beep, beep, beep!
That's so cool!
It turns back into the chandelier?
Wow!
You have a very important job ahead of you tonight, sir.
Ah, yummy.
I'm gonna possess the grapes.
Dang it!
No vore tonight, everybody.
Let's see...
Projector...
Lamp...
Let's operate this thing.
Darn.
This is a pickle?
No, those are grapes!
The phone and I got put away neatly.
The only thing I've learned is that the name...
is the name Lynn.
This sure is a weird room.
Travel through the...
Travel through the phone line to get here.
But where exactly is here?
And who exactly are these people?
Boo!
Ah, you like it!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Boo!
Yes, boo!
Am I lagging, by the way, sometimes?
I can't tell.
God, man!
What are you trying to give me?
A case of the vapors?
My apologies, sir, but I did not touch it, sir.
It appears the equipment is still malfunctioning, sir.
Bah!
Granted, technology is...
Granted, technology is certainly a convenient thing.
I'm smooth.
But our use of it is just plain off, confound it.
Hmm, yes.
In any case, I don't wish to see the face of our current target, my good man.
As you wish, sir.
In that case, might I suggest this, sir?
Beep!
It changes to...
Oh, my gosh, I was thinking it changes to like a Mint Phantom stream.
Might I suggest this, sir?
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep!
Opens up Vtuber stream.
Hey, that's...
Mmm, yes.
Cecil?
If all goes well with our deal tonight, we will have the power to change the world, sir.
Yes, sir.
Hmm, yes.
It's a very important night indeed, my good man.
We cannot afford to make mistakes.
Sissel...
That is why we can't afford to trust that Sissel.
No, we must be very careful.
John Sissel Ghost Trick.
Sissel!
That must be my name!
Now that I hear it, it does sound familiar.
A deal, eh?
What could that be all about?
So what exactly was I up to, I wonder?
No, sir.
Yes, sir.
Thank you for the no, sir.
We are completely prepared for tonight, sir.
Hmm, yes.
Now all we have to do is pluck the fruit of success.
One thing's clear.
These villains seem to know me.
Infinite Grapes.
I wish.
How can we make this a reality?
And another thing...
There seems to be some kind of connection between me and this Lin.
Why else would our names both come up here like this?
Hmm, going Ghost.
I'm going Lamp.
Can't... I guess we gotta... Oh wait.
I can't reach.
Ugh.
Curse this tiny, wispy body of mine.
Okay, let's just operate the lamp again.
Or the projector.
Where is your head, man?
I told you I don't wish to see this face.
My apologies, sir.
It appears to be another malfunction, sir.
Well, get it fixed, man.
Unless you want to see me.
Malfunction.
Certainly, sir.
I'm gonna make this guy go crazy.
These guys murdered me, and now they're targeting the redhead.
What kind of connection do we have with each other?
Spinning this painting around makes the old man's head spin.
But that's about it.
Got to find the right timing and get...
Ahhhh.
Um...
When it spins...
Oh, I can possess the painting.
Okay, okay, okay.
Um...
Okay, okay.
I got it.
There we go.
First try, baby.
A love connection.
Ooh la la!
My apologies, sir.
Okay.
Certainly, sir.
Very good.
These guys murdered me, and now they're... Oh yeah.
What kind of connection?
La la la.
Oh, what's he saying?
I say, this room is giving me the heebie-jeebies, my good man.
What?
With paintings spinning around and the like, it's enough to give the man... a man the jitters.
My apologies, sir.
The room was just completed recently, sir.
We're still trying to iron out the kinks, sir.
Hmm, yes.
I just hope that's all it is.
Haha.
Little did I know.
I'm causing chaos... in their workplace.
Get your heads out of the gutter.
I mean...
EGAD, man!
How am I supposed to relax and enjoy my grapes?
So true.
Okay, we can operate that.
We can become fruit.
Look, we're just a little fruit!
Oh no, he's gonna eat us for real.
Okay.
Let's operate this now.
Trick!
Goodbye, fruit.
It's a miserable state of affairs when I can't even be startled by a telephone that doesn't even ring.
Wah!
EGAD!
Become fruit.
It's even more pathetic to be startled by the same telephone twice.
Bah!
The problem must be solved, sir.
Dismiss Lynn's problems, sir.
What?
Lynn?
Hmm, yes.
You did mention taking the next step a moment ago.
Didn't you, my good man?
You were saying?
Yes, sir.
I sent one step ahe- Wait, one step ahead tango.
Hahaha.
So we had...
Nearsighted Jenga, and now one step ahead tango.
So that's what he meant by being one step ahead?
A telephone...
That telephone call must be him reporting in, sir.
Very good.
Oh no, is she dead?
Uh-oh.
Lynn is in danger again!
I'm going ghost!
Oh!
Here we go.
Hahaha.
This is one step ahead tango.
I'm at the target's apartment now.
And out with it, man!
Have you taken care of her?
No, she isn't back yet.
What?
Does she have fish?
Is he a fiend?
Is she eating her fish?
It only stands with reason- Oh, to reason.
If the target got here first, they wouldn't call me one step ahead, now would they?
That's so true.
At her apartment, he's one step ahead?
Exactly!
I don't get it.
But in any case, man, once you've taken care of her- Then you'll promote me to the head of the hitman division?
Bah!
No, man!
You're even getting one step ahead of me!
We can discuss my new salary later.
Great Scott!
Now you're even getting one step ahead of your last one step ahead!
This guy's so ambitious, we love it.
We love a guy boss.
Girl boss?
I'll get back to my job now, sir.
Confounded!
You're even hanging up on one step ahead!
Yes, girl boss, that promotion!
Yes!
What did he say, sir?
He asked me to raise his salary.
This game is so goofy.
What will you do, sir?
Maybe I'll give him some of nearsighted- Oh, Jigo!
Oh, Tango and Jigo.
I called him- I called him Jango, I think.
Jigo, Jigo, Jigo.
That makes sense.
Jigo.
Jigo Tango.
I go.
We go.
Jigo Tango.
One go.
Two go.
Blue go.
Red go.
Nearsighted ahead Jango.
I can't lose her!
She's my only lead if I ever hope to solve the mystery of me!
Here we go!
Oh my gosh, we're going to her apartment!
How exciting.
Jigoku and Tengoku.
That's so...
He did not kill the dog.
Did he kill the dog?
No!
The telephone line guided me to Lin's apartment.
Fortunately, Lin isn't here yet.
But unfortunately, the hitman is.
Oh my gosh.
She's got like giant...
Giant like...
What are those cheesy rings?
And a bowl.
And there are a couple of other unfortunate little developments waiting for me, it seems.
No!
Oh!
Who is that?
Oh my gosh.
What?
Hmm.
It looks like there's an unlikely...
Unlucky little lady here tonight.
No, not an unlucky little lady.
I didn't even unlock the door.
Oh!
That's a dog.
No!
No, no, no!
That's a dog.
A poor brave little warrior.
We'll save him, we'll save him.
We'll save him.
He must have been trying to defend his mistress.
No!
Not the dog.
If Lin came home now, I have to do something about this situation and fast.
Can we go back in time and save the dog?
Oh!
Well, that's it.
I'm gonna go back in time.
I think we can.
And more to the point, who am I?
Oh, wait, the dog can talk?
Who am I?
I guess that explains why this dog is talking to me right now.
This is your mistress's apartment, and you are... presumably the little doggy who died here.
Died?
So I'm dead, woof?
Let's see, the dead lose their memories.
They even forget what they look like.
And so that's what this blue flame shape is all about.
Oh, woof!
There's no time to lose, woof!
Miss Camilla!
My Miss Camilla is in trouble, woof!
You mean you remember?
You know who you are?
Woof!
That's right, I'm Missle!
Missle!
Nice to meet you!
I'm a Pomeranian!
Woof!
Wow.
I guess now I know it's possible for the dead to regain their memories.
Missle.
Thanks to this little doggy.
Miss Camilla!
My Miss Camilla is in trouble, and I vow to devote my life to protecting her, woof!
Oh my gosh, pretty!
Thank you for the 50 gifted!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
But I died before I could rescue her.
How could I let her down like this, woof?
So you're more worried about your mistress's safety than your own death, eh?
I like your moxie, little doggy.
Looks like it's time to go back to four minutes before this little guy's death.
This time to save... time to save this... wait.
Time...
That's not me, right?
Time to save... this... his... life.
Time to save this his life!
Updated the phonebook.
Rewind.
And I saw that I could open up the door of the... door we possessed right before possessing the Maison de Amida.
Let's see.
First of all, I'd better see what I can find out before your death, little guy.
Excuse me, but... where exactly are we?
Huh?
You... you follow me?
I followed you.
You brought me with you.
One or the other.
Hmm.
It looks like the dead can move around together.
This is the land of four minutes before your death.
Really?
We're really here?
So that means you're going to save Miss Camilla, doesn't it?
Missile both in Ghost Trick and in Ace Attorney is based on Shu Takumi's Shiba.
He passed away a few years ago.
Oh no!
So the doggo's name is Nikita or Stinger.
Looks like a Nikita to me, right?
Missile...
Aren't you even surprised?
I mean, we just traveled through time and... not especially.
I mean, Miss Camilla can walk around on two legs, but I can't do that.
So if she can do that, then it's not so strange that you can walk backwards through time.
So that's the way your mind works, eh?
I guess that's reasonable enough.
Sorry.
Come on, come on!
Let's get started!
First, we watch your last four minutes unfold.
Then we use what we learned to save Camilla.
Just like when I saved Lin at the junkyard.
If we watch closely, we ought to be able to get a few leads.
Keep your eyes open!
Of course!
Leave it to me to sniff out a few clues!
Okay.
Oh, she's under the couch for...
some reason?
She's so cute!
Yippee!
I found the revolt!
Oh, that is so... How are you able to watch anything?
Oh my god, the dog is doing otagei.
Oh, who the heck is that?
Oh my...
Shut that mutt up!
No, Missile!
You're not supposed to bark!
The art here... particularly reminds me of... Poppin'.
The lady next door is crappier than ever tonight.
If it barks again... I'll knock this wall down!
Kind of Mega Man?
Maybe if I would... Poppin' mention.
Lady hate.
Yeah!
Yeah, who's gonna pay for... I don't think knocking the wall down is gonna solve your problems.
I think it's gonna make it even worse.
Actually, Ace Attorney missile came before, then Shu Takumi's missile, then Ghost Trick missile.
Whoever sent the super chat before you got an actual lead.
You don't want her to knock down the wall, do you?
Why do you like to bark so much anyway?
Um, actually...
You sure are cute.
But just don't get us killed, okay?
Ish.
Darn, I really wanted to watch TV too.
Hey, I know!
I'll listen to music!
La la la la la la...
Oh no, that's why she probably couldn't hear the guy...
Who, uh...
Okay, so we're gonna have to...
Oh.
Whew, that was close!
We're gonna have to knock her music into the water.
So that she can't hear.
Or so she can't listen.
Because otherwise she's gonna miss the guy.
I'm in the mood for donuts tonight.
Look at the tail.
It's just like her.
It's like her hair.
Oh no, no...
What?!
Oh my gosh, do we have a rat infestation?
Uh oh, he's gonna bark.
Oh no!
I'll knock this wall down!
Oh my god, this is so bad.
Remy?
Why...
Why has he got like a scope like that?
Hmm.
I don't really like it when jobs outside the original scope crop up.
I have to put it down as a separate charge.
And accounting never likes that.
Oh my god, point blank!
But I guess it can't be helped.
Sorry, kid.
I'm...
Did it show anything?
I closed my...
Because I closed my eyes.
I couldn't watch.
It faded to white?
Okay, good.
Oh my god.
So that's the whole dramatic story of what happened four minutes before you died!
Wow, look at that!
I'm dead!
I'm kind of shocked to tell the truth.
Okay, let's get started on saving her!
Let's see.
How are we going to do this?
Seems to me the easiest way would be for you to take a big bite out of that man's leg.
I don't think I could do that.
Whenever somebody I don't know comes around, all I want to say to them is, Welcome!
I can't help it!
This dog is so cute.
What a good boy.
Who's a good boy?
Okay, then I guess the only thing we can do is to get the little lady to help herself somehow.
I don't think she could do that.
Did you notice her putting those red things on her head?
Oh, you mean the headphones.
Whenever she puts those red things on, that's it!
I can call her name until my throat is sore, but she never hears me!
That is very dangerous.
I feel so much anxiety if I...
Because you know how most earbuds nowadays have...
What's the word?
You can do noise cancelling, and then you can do where you have the...
It's where you can hear the world as well.
Transparency?
Transparent mode?
Pass through?
Something like that.
I guess it depends on what earbuds you have.
Ambient mode?
I think mine is called ambient mode.
But yeah, if I'm not in ambient mode, I get so much anxiety.
Because it's like...
I only have...
I only do noise cancelling on planes.
But...
Girl didn't even hear a gunshot.
I know!
That's what I'm saying!
To be perfectly honest, I hate those red things.
You're right.
With those headphones on, our little lady doesn't even hear the sound of the intruder's gun.
So maybe that's our first lead.
Now we know...
We have to do something about that.
I'm scared!
I'm nervous!
Trick time!
I'm going ghost.
Alright.
Open the door.
We can extend it!
Okay.
Extend.
It doesn't...
Retract?
Maybe?
Oh.
So close!
You almost knocked those red things down!
I think you're onto something there.
If we drop them in the fish tank...
See?
I said it earlier.
We have to drop them in the fish tank.
Camilla won't be able to use them anymore.
But if we drop them in the fish tank, Miss Camilla will get a scolding from Miss Lin.
All you have to do is pretend it was your fault.
That's the way of the honorable warrior.
Okay.
180 IQ?
Are you calling me stupid?
Like a genome soldier?
Are you calling me dumb?
180 is good though.
I don't know.
I played Metal Gear.
You've obviously never seen Miss Lin when she gets mad.
I think she'll understand if...
Let's see.
We have a telephone.
What happens if I open this?
I think the dog is barking.
There's nothing else I can reach though.
If I extend it again...
Oh wait.
Okay.
I saw the check mark.
I see.
It's a little over there.
...
Hmm.
Is there any...
...
Can I dial?
Oh that's funny.
Wait, what's wrong?
This telephone doesn't seem to be working right now.
Usually the telephone line glows red, but it's dark right now.
Looks like I can't use the telephone line in the 4 minutes before death roll.
Okay.
Wheeee.
Hmm.
Hold fast-forward through already red dial to the bottom of the screen.
Oh, thank you!
You literally called yourself stupid at the start of the stream?
There's stuff over there!
I want to see it.
Hold on.
This is where she says you're not supposed to bark...
Do I just keep trying?
No...
It's not gonna work.
I can't get close to anything.
This is where she says...
Oh, no!
I didn't mean to...
I pressed X instead of Y.
How do I fast forward?
Oh, there we go.
Nice.
This is where she says...
Well, maybe we have to time it when she listens to the music, right?
So...
Maybe when she grabs it, we extend it.
We knock it out of her hands.
Time is passing.
Nice.
There we go.
Oh, no!
Darn!
How did I manage to do that?
Lynn just bought those headphones too!
Wrecked.
Whoopsie.
How about if we tell her you did it, Missile?
Everybody 07 for this honorable warrior taking the fall.
Missile.
Missile 07, Missile.
Your fall will not be in vain.
Woof woof.
Darn.
Now, I can't even listen to music either.
I think the gods are playing tricks on me tonight.
Forgive me, Miss Camila.
I'm only doing it to save you.
So what?
Now you think you're one of the gods, eh?
I'm a god.
I'm a god!
Huh?
No.
Never mind that.
The important thing is we managed to change the situation.
Sorry, I'm like chewing.
That's true.
At least we can now use the little lady's ears to help us.
DJ Cat, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Oh, we got more time.
Mood for donuts tonight.
Hello.
The question is, what do we do now?
Yeah.
Mio-chan, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Unless we do something more, the outcome will still be the same.
If only I had big strong teeth and an aggressive spirit.
The god of maids.
Doesn't it seem like we can stop the hidden man from coming in?
So, yeah, um, do you not lock your doors?
I have an idea.
Why don't we hide Miss Camilla?
Hide, huh?
That sounds just like the kind of idea a little doggy would come up with.
Are you making fun of me?
But where could a little lady hide in this room?
We have the Christmas tree.
We have under the couch.
I think I might have just the place.
But there's just one little problem.
How to get Miss Camilla in there, right?
Oh, sorry.
My friend Emory is playing Mario.
Exactly.
If I could possess Camilla herself, the answer would be easy.
But I can't do that, so I guess the only way to do it is to lead her here.
Now, what can I do using the objects in this room?
I think I'll try out various things and see what I can come up with.
And I'll be here watching, cheering you on.
Okay, now I can possess this.
We can rock the bowl.
Let's rock the bowl.
Time is passing.
I'm sorry, little mouse.
Sorry, I just unplugged my controller.
There we go.
Because I thought it was... I was charging it while I was playing.
Okay.
Sorry.
Maybe that stopped the dog from barking though, right?
Move.
If you bark like that, you'll make the lady next door start howling.
If you keep this up, that wall is going to come down on our heads before we know it.
But you'll protect me from anything if anything bad happens, right, Missile?
Of course I will.
That's quite a big promise for a little fellow.
The poor little guy is up against some formidable opponents.
The man in black and the woman in purple.
What about the... wait, the rat.
Maybe she needs to see the rat and hide from it because she's scared, right?
We might have to redo.
Maybe she gets scared of the rat.
Time is passing.
Why do you always give your mistress so much trouble?
Guess I'm truly embarrassed by my own behavior.
But when that little guy starts squeaking, it gets me all in an uproar.
And when I bark, Miss Camilla always comes over and gives me a nice hug.
We might be able to take advantage of that for...
Take advantage of that piece of information.
Huh?
How?
Wherever the donut falls, the rat shows up to check it out.
Oooh.
And then you go and bark at the rat.
And then our little lady comes to you and to quiet you down.
That's just the way things work, I'm afraid.
So in other words, the donut can be the bait that will lead the little lady to where we want her.
Okay.
What's that up there?
Oh my god.
Sorry.
Please.
Missile.
You're stressing me out.
Let's try moving again.
Oh no, it goes back to the other spot.
Where'd the donuts go?
It's written into your jeans.
The destiny to bark.
Over here.
There's no way I can get over in these spots yet.
So let's drop another donut.
She's reaching for the donuts again.
So cute.
Okay, you rock.
Oh, it didn't work this time.
Damn, she is downing those donuts.
I can't make another donut fall.
What do we do now?
Without the donut, the squeaky guy won't come in.
I won't bark.
Looks like only one donut will fall.
But the donut is the only bait that will lead the little lady to where we want her.
Maybe I should rethink my plan of attack.
I mean, this plays and we can...
make her bark, right?
Oh my god.
I might have to redo, yeah.
But let's...
It's said that maybe we should sometimes wait until the end.
So let's not just stop right now, I think.
The spinning Santa.
Can I reach it?
Oh, I can, I can.
Nice.
Oh, but I can't reach anything.
Oh, rotate faster.
Whee!
Yeah!
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm so close.
Nice.
Latch.
What's this?
Oh.
Oh, time is passing.
Oh gosh, I'm scared.
Okay, there we go.
Okay.
Oh, wrong.
Okay, there we go.
What's this?
Rock the painting?
That didn't do anything?
Okay.
Maybe let's rotate slower.
The painting rocked.
Yes.
Okay, nice.
We can get to the lamp.
We can get to the door.
This will open it and do that.
And then we have a little ball.
A little ball for the dog.
Right?
You sent that thing flying.
I like to tidy up by shoving eyesores under the sofa.
How come you're looking at me when you say that?
Hey, wait a minute.
Under the sofa, eh?
Yes.
That might be a spot where the Hitman wouldn't look.
Come to think of it, Miss Camilla climbs under the sofa all the time.
Why?
Trying to catch me.
Oh, I'm scared.
You're a naughty little doggy, aren't you?
You naughty little doggy.
Which makes him a bad Hitman.
He's not near-sighted.
He's one step ahead, okay?
He doesn't know.
So my new plan is to hide the little lady under the sofa.
The only problem is, how do I lead her under there?
Ah, yes.
A very good question indeed.
We don't have much time left.
Okay.
And then we knock this music box down, but I don't think it's doing much.
Oh, I think we have to act- maybe the dog is asleep, so if we play the ornament, the dog might notice the ball underneath, right?
Shut that mud up.
Does he notice it?
No, he didn't.
He fell back asleep.
Oh my god.
Let's go away.
Three!
What do you mean three?
Looks like I'm down to a few more seconds!
Ms. Camilla!
We have to do something!
We just have to!
Now now, getting worked up isn't going to help.
We're down to the wire here.
Do we have enough time to do something to change her fate?
Or is it time to use another one of my ghost tricks?
Another ghost trick?
What is it?
We could rewind time and start all over again from four minutes ago.
Whatever we do, we'd better hurry.
Hurry!
Oh jeez.
Um, how can I possess the ball?
I don't think there's anything else I can do.
Like I can move the cart.
Would that do anything?
Okay, worth a shot, right?
Move the cart.
Oh my god, two!
It didn't change anything!
Um...
It's fantover.
It's mintover.
Oh...
Make the donut fall.
We can't.
There's only one.
Wait, okay, I have a question.
So if she dies, I can still, like, I can still rewind.
I just, um...
I can rewind at any time, but even if she dies, I can rewind still, right?
Yeah, you can still restart.
Okay, okay.
The game deletes your save.
Okay.
Rocket!
Oh my god.
I don't think there's anything I can do.
I'm gonna open the door!
Make that rat go flying!
I think we're donezo.
We're so donezo.
Uh...
Oh my god, why don't you lock your door?
Bite him!
Oh my god.
Listen up, little girl.
I'll make you a deal.
If you promise to keep quiet, I'll let you live.
For now, anyway.
What a shame.
But I guess this brave little fellow refuses to accept...
He's a dog!
Missile!
No!
Okay.
Ooh!
Time's up.
Doesn't seem like I can stop the intruder from coming in.
Guess this little doggy doesn't have much fighting power.
People often tell me my name doesn't suit me.
Guess the only thing to do is hide our little lady someplace where the hitman can't see her.
Yeah.
Okay, let's rewind time!
After fate change...
Wait.
Fate change?
What?
Yeah, yeah.
We'll start from the fate change.
Because that didn't have anything to do with the donuts.
Then we don't have to do the...
We don't have to wait for the...
For the headphones again.
Okay.
We probably shouldn't let that guy go flying.
We probably...
Shouldn't let that little guy go flying.
But...
I think we should move the cart over here.
And...
I also...
Don't want to exactly wait...
Or I want to have the ball under there as well, I think.
I think it would help to have the ball under there too.
Oh, wait.
There we go.
Okay.
I still am curious about this music box though.
Rotate faster.
Tremble.
Hit.
Let's open that.
Oh my God.
Thank you for the...
50 gifted wandering tacos.
Thank you.
Oh wait.
Oh, no.
I was right.
Okay.
Never mind.
Oh my gosh.
Please.
Okay.
There we go.
I don't think there's anything we can do with the painting that I know of.
I also can't reach it.
Oh wait!
Oh shoot.
I just realized we...
We have to do the star first.
Sometimes the going back and forth makes me like a little...
Or like the going ghost mode and not ghost mode makes me a little...
Woo!
Okay.
Now the star.
Yeah, a little motion sick.
There we go.
And when it starts going fast, it can hurt the eyes.
Yeah, just a little.
What does it say here?
If you bark like that, how can anybody enjoy the pretty melody?
And your poor mistress has to get up and quiet you down every time.
Yes, I am... Oh.
Look at that.
One of the ornaments fell off.
The tree.
Not interested in things like that.
I graduated from playing with balls a long time ago.
You should try graduating from meatless barking too.
Sorry.
That's one thing I could never give up.
Okay.
Here.
I don't think it hurts to have this done, you know?
To have it there.
I think.
I don't think it hurts to have it.
Under the couch.
That's what I mean.
Okay, now rock?
Wait, it goes that way?
Oh my gosh, it's a little pink mouse!
Uh...
Oh!
And then I...
Okay, hold on.
Do I fling her?
Do I fling...
Wait, which way does it open?
I think I fling the mouse this way, right?
Dr. Okay.
Okay.
The heat cool.
Aww.
What are you doing under here, you silly boy?
First don't know, currently going through exams.
And love watching along while studying.
Thanks for the fun streams.
Thanks rainy girl, good luck with yours.
Oh, exams.
Almost said your streams...
Good luck with your exams!
I'm taking another bite.
Dr.
Thank you.
Aw, my little missile.
You're always doing the cutest things.
Okay.
Nobody's here, right?
Oh my god.
This guy is deaf.
He can't hear the dog going...
My prey is bound to come home sometime.
Might as well make myself comfortable in the meantime.
Meanwhile, you better not eat a doughnut.
Don't do it!
There, our little lady's fate has been averted.
Let's go!
We got it!
We got it, we got it.
It has?
The poor thing is still curled up in a ball and shaking with fear.
Well, yeah, that's true.
But that's not so bad.
In the scheme of things, I'd say she's just fine.
And look, you're not dead.
Oh, you're right!
We did it!
We did it, didn't we?
Well, to be precise, you're the one who did it.
Huh?
Me?
I saved Miss Camilla?
Yup.
You're the one who led her under the sofa, right?
You protected your mistress.
I can attest to that.
Oh.
Oh, thank you!
Fate averted!
Can I ask a question?
Sure, what is it?
What exactly are those strange powers of yours?
Hitman, I'm going to take this donut and eat it!
Stop, ancient meme!
Oh, you mean my ghost tricks?
Apparently, they're the power to manipulate inanimate objects.
So they're ghost tricks?
Oh, sorry, if they're...
Yeah, they're ghost tricks.
If they're ghost tricks, then can I do them too?
I'm dead too, after all.
I guess?
That's how it goes.
No, remember?
The lamp said we're special.
I've been staring at those donuts as hard as I could for a long time now.
But they won't budge for me.
Why do you suppose that is?
I don't really know.
I guess you just don't have that power.
Well, I have one thing to say to that.
That's not fair!
Sorry, but I guess not everyone who dies gets the power of the dead.
So what's going to happen to me now?
Nothing really.
Your death has been erased.
Oh my gosh, can you imagine if I like...
What if I got four minutes to go back and like not be dead?
What if I wasn't a ghost?
What if I wasn't a ghost maid?
What if I was just a normal maid?
Wouldn't that be so weird?
Do you guys prefer me dead or...
Would you rather me be living and happy and like thriving in life?
Or would you rather me be a sad, sad afterlife ghost?
The dead thing kind of suits me.
One ghost, please.
Just don't be sad.
You're so right!
I'm going to take a walk tomorrow.
You'll just go back to being a happy little doggy.
Living your everyday life.
See?
He's going to go back to being a happy, alive dog.
Not a sad, dead dog.
This is a trick question.
A ghost trick question!
I guess this means goodbye.
But...
We'll meet again sometime, right?
Yeah, maybe.
If you die again?
What you did for me tonight?
I'll never...
I'll never forget it!
I guess we'd better get...
Get it...
We...
We'd better...
We'd better get...
Getting back...
Wait...
We'd better...
I guess we'd better be getting back to the present.
Time to see what happens next in our story.
I'm okay.
I hope the dog doesn't bark.
Gosh.
Okay, and now a new present is born.
The little lady is still curled up in a ball and shaking with fear.
And the little doggy is wagging his tail happily.
So what am I going to do now?
I think I'll watch for a while and see what happens.
I hope I didn't mess up with the ball though.
But we have the music box.
I have a question.
Does this game only have one way to complete a...
A thing?
A puzzle?
This is like asking your girlfriend...
Wait.
This is like your girlfriend asking you, do I look fat?
Still at the junkyard.
All right.
Got it.
I'm on my way.
Oh, yes.
Hmm.
I guess my prey likes to play hide and seek.
She hasn't had enough of that junkyard yet.
Apparently.
I can't let near sighted Jigo beat me out of this one.
I'd better hurry.
Oh, is he leaving?
He's just leaving?
Okay.
Nice.
Lock the door.
Please lock the door.
What was that all about?
Opens the door with the rifle.
I know.
He's so cool.
You saved me, didn't you, Missile?
I just know you did.
Oh my gosh.
Maybe I shouldn't answer it.
Answers it anyway.
Okay.
Moshi moshi.
Lin!
Trick time.
Oh?
What am I trick timing to?
A call from Lin, eh?
Sounds serious.
I wonder...
Oh, yeah.
Better go possess that phone and listen in.
Oh, no.
Wait.
Oh.
I didn't realize I was on the...
Oh, no.
Another call.
There we go.
And...
Round we go.
And over we...
Oh.
There's the little doggy all curled up on the floor.
Dreaming away the life we worked so hard to get back for.
That's fine.
But what's up with that core?
The phone works again.
Mysterious.
Yeah, it said like we couldn't use the phone in the four minutes.
Say his name!
It's Ray!
I'm obsessed with possessing.
It's you!
Come to think of it, I never did ask your name.
I guess it's good we ran into each other again then.
This music is so happy.
This is a good chance for us to reintroduce ourselves to each other.
You mean you forgot my name already?
After everything we shared together?
The drama?
That tearful goodbye?
I'm Misa!
And I'm Minto!
But you know, it's strange.
I wonder why you remember me now that you're alive again.
Do you remember your time being dead?
Of course!
All of it!
Okay, let me get this straight.
The memory of being dead doesn't disappear.
And the dead I meet in the ghost world develop a core when they return to the land of the living.
Then if I possess that core, I can talk to that person.
I have to remember that I died?
Okay...
It's a little traumatic, isn't it?
Poor Miso.
There's not a thought behind that eyes.
But every day he just sees himself staring down the barrel.
Pointed directly at his face.
He's just like, haha, I'm traumatized.
It looks that way, yes.
Cool.
Oh, thank goodness you're okay.
Well, I don't know if I'm okay exactly.
You won't believe what just happened.
Listen to me.
You've got to get out of there right now.
What about dinner?
I was thinking about spaghetti tonight.
Yeah, spaghetti!
I've been murdered before.
Really?
Me too.
Nah, I'm just kidding.
Nah.
Unless...
Ah, I'm eating more.
I won't be going back there for a while and you might be in danger.
You might be in danger if you stay there too.
But I already was in danger.
Just a little while ago.
Oh, wow.
Lin, could you like, care at all?
Meet me at that restaurant on Chicken Kitchen.
Oh, sorry.
The Chicken Kitchen.
On Dead End Drive.
Dead End Drive?
I don't know.
That's pretty far.
Just hurry, okay?
Oh, and one more thing.
Bring the music box with you, okay?
Music box?
Oh, we got it!
I love music boxes!
Is it a present for me?
I'm sorry, but it doesn't play.
I can't even get the lid open.
Then you can't very well call it a music box.
Then can you?
More like just a box.
Just a box.
Just bring it, okay?
It's kind of big and it's made out of wood.
Okay, I will.
Where is it?
I kind of hid it in that room here.
Oh, well, we already got it.
We sped run it.
Who the hell are you?
Oh my god.
Excuse me.
Eek!
Lynn!
Oh no!
Oh my god.
Cliffhanger.
Cliffhanger!
Not again.
Darn.
Now I've dropped the phone in there too.
What did it...
Wouldn't it be corded?
Like, you know, those kinds of...
It looks really old.
Poor fish.
Right?
The fish just got electrocuted.
How about if we tell her you did it, Missile?
Woof!
I sure hope Lynn's alright.
I'd better get going.
I know right where Dead End Drive is.
But I never saw any music box around here.
Where am I supposed to find it?
Do you know where it is, Missile?
Oh my gosh.
Dora the Explorer time.
Do you know where the music box is?
Say...
Here.
If you know where the music box is.
Where's the music box?
Over there.
Where is the music box?
Under the couch?
Are you stupid?
That's a ball.
Don't you know your basic shapes?
On the tree?
Good job.
Time to tr...
Oh my gosh.
Look at her.
She's searching.
It's so cute.
Oh no.
She missed it.
Wait.
How am I supposed to...
Oh.
Maybe I let this go off and she'll see it.
She saw it.
Dora for 30-year-olds.
This is it.
The music box.
She's
about to say yippee.
I think...
Is she me?
I'll leave the remote here.
We're good.
But don't you touch it, Missile.
If the TV comes on, you'll start barking.
I'd hate to find you flattened underneath that wall when I came home.
Dora for 30-year-olds.
She looks so genuinely sad about that.
All the stuff that's just in the fish tank.
Stay here and be a good boy.
I'm leaving now, Missile.
I have to go help Lin.
She's like a sister to me, you know?
You be good, my boy.
And no barking.
Woof.
Still no peace for the little lady, and the redhead Lin is facing a new crisis right now as well.
Can your next stream be a key jingling stream?
Meanwhile, I'm a bit in a pickle of my own.
With the receiver at the bottom of the fish tank, I find myself still trapped in this apartment.
Too bad I can't just curl up and go to sleep with my team.
Tail wagging too.
Because there is something I must do.
The question is, how do I go about getting out of here?
Do you guys need me to jingle keys for you to pay attention?
Yay!
7.31 to 8.04!
New song.
Welcome to the salon.
Nice.
Yes, please.
Tiki-tiki-tiki-tiki-tiki-tiki.
Hahaha.
The passion.
She saw it as probably the most key jingling...
jingle core stream you've done so far.
It was like my second stream.
Sorry, I wasn't paying attention.
Oh.
Tiki-tiki-tiki-tiki-tiki.
What was I saying?
Oh no, maybe I need the keys more than you got.
I need them too!
Oh no, we're stuck in a loop of people who don't pay attention and don't know what's going on.
Once again, Lin is in danger.
And I think she knows it too.
I sincerely doubt she'll be coming back to this apartment tonight.
She and I are connected to each other somehow.
She's my only lead and I can't lose her.
I have to get to her.
And fast.
You jingle the keys for us, we jingle the keys for you.
Nice!
I'm paying attention.
I see all the keys in chat.
Okay, I'm paying attention.
Maybe I get the remote.
I'm paying attention.
Hey doggie.
If she does knock the wall down, then we'll be able to use her phone.
See?
Oh my god, wait, she's actually going to knock it down.
If you keep that racket up, I'll bring this whole dilapidated building down on you.
Ding-a-ling-a-ling-a-ling-a-ling.
Keep barking, missile!
Did you hear what I just heard?
You mean the lady next door is angry.
Howl!
No, forget that.
Tomoe!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
That was the sound of a telephone ringing.
Coming from the apartment next door.
Oh, I get it.
You're thinking about borrowing her telephone, aren't you?
Saying it with that voice is a little funny.
But how are you going to do that without breaking the wall down?
Well, the lady next door is kindly offering to do it for us.
Yes, but she's mostly hoping to crush me underneath it.
Just keep doing it.
Oh no, I didn't mean to make it go faster.
Slow down a little.
Slow.
Just calm down.
Wyvern.
Dragon.
Wyvern droog.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Oh, we're so close.
Can I rock?
Oh, it doesn't rock enough.
I was thinking like it'll rock side to side and I could like rock it over here.
There's also up here, but I don't think there's anything I can get in there.
Hmm.
I'd rather not.
Thanks for the vibe, Gifte.
Thank you.
Talk to him?
Come on now.
Can't you bark any louder than that?
Louder!
But then that lady will knock the wall down on top of me.
We'll worry about that when it happens.
Anyway...
I don't... like... who's gonna pay for that?
Ghost Trick is one of my faves.
Hope you enjoy it and play it all the way through.
I will!
Thanks, Sneakson!
We need to have this little doggy put some more energy into it.
Let's see.
Wasn't there something else around here that gets a reaction out of him?
Uh... the star?
So we do the star and the... the show?
Oh!
There it goes.
Oh my god!
I'll pound this... oh my god!
Holy cow!
Woah!
Did she just knock the dog unconscious?
I told you, didn't I?
I told you I would knock the wall down on you.
He's okay, right?
Dog?
Oh.
So this is what it feels like to have a wall knocked down on you, huh?
It's more like she knocked you out through the wall, really.
Oh my gosh, Tomo-boy!
Thank you for the 50-gifted thank you!
I'm still alive, aren't I?
Yes?
You are.
But the TV and the star ornament aren't.
I'll never bark again!
Not as long as I live!
But wait a minute...
It looks like... Here, one second.
I'm gonna actually make this a bit smaller.
Just so it's not so in the way.
Sorry, guys.
I'm still trying to figure out how to...
When there's so many gifted memberships...
Oh my gosh, Tomo-boy!
Thank you for another 50!
When there's so many memberships, it kind of like...
It kind of like keeps them popping up for so long, so...
The notifications... I'm so sorry.
But thank you so much!
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
It looks like all that commotion wasn't for naught.
Huh?
Ooh, your barking made her create a path for me!
It did?
But the wall is still standing just like before!
But there are paths only the dead can see.
Oh, those kinds of paths!
Trick time!
There we go.
Nice.
Easy peasy.
Bye, missile!
So you're leaving, huh?
I guess so.
You're going to go save Miss Camilla and Miss Lin?
I have to follow my own mystery first and foremost.
That means everything to me.
But you will save them, right?
If it helps me along the way, then yes.
I don't have any powers of the dead.
I'm not even dead, actually.
But I'm going to find a way to go help Miss Camilla, too.
We create our own paths.
Right, missile?
That's right!
Okay, I'm leaving now.
Guess this is our second goodbye.
It is, isn't it?
My name is Sissel.
If we ever meet again, that's what you can call me.
Sissel, huh?
Got it.
You know what, Sissel?
I'm going to create my own path.
Just like you said.
She goes to sleep.
Missile?
Missile!
Missile, please!
Can dogs get concussions?
Tonight is the holiest of all nights.
My deadline.
All I need is to get some inspiration.
From the Muses is this bottle and some cheese.
Here it's to the boorish people next door.
Nice, we're inside this lady's house.
Oh my god, there's a mouse!
Who's sneezing?
Her hair is like a tulip.
This is sexy music.
Are you alright, my darling angel?
Have you taken your medicine like a good girl?
Oh!
Oh, she's got that gamer posture.
She's perfect.
Here I am in yet another strange room.
With...
What's with the oddly tense air of this place anyway?
Now where is that little treasure I'm looking for?
Who's in the bed?
There it is.
The telephone.
Now if I can just borrow it...
Who's in the bed though?
I'm so curious.
Let's see, we got this...
Oh, I can't reach that, can I?
Oh, I can!
I'm just gonna...
We're just gonna let that go through.
And we're just gonna poke you a little bit.
And we're just gonna scooch you a little bit.
I don't know why I'm doing all of this.
Oh my god, look at her go!
Wait, what is she saying?
Oh, Mr. Prime Minister.
You mustn't.
I'm a married woman.
And I'm a married man.
But we cannot resist this any longer.
I'm ready to abdicate it all for you.
She's writing fanfiction!
Even if it means my ultimate ruination.
Ruination...
Hmm...
Is that even a word?
And that abdicate just doesn't look right somehow.
This is going to nag me all night, I'm sure.
Oh my god, philosophy!
Thanks for the vibe, gifted.
Um...
Boom...
Examine?
Where is that dictionary?
This thing is too heavy.
I can't manipulate it.
Maybe that woman built up her destructive power by hefting this puppy.
It's more like a weapon than a book.
Let's see.
I know I put it here somewhere.
Now where could it have gone to?
Um...
Trick!
I still...
It's too heavy.
Uh...
I just can't find it.
Wait, the mouse is back!
Um...
How do I time this?
Hmm...
Oh...
No, I mustn't.
I mustn't allow myself to believe in your love, Mr. Prime Minister.
But why...
Wait, is that...
Is this him speaking?
But why won't you believe in me?
My love for you is true.
I swear.
And it's so strong.
It overwhelms me!
You know, I've always wondered...
If you can be overwhelmed by something...
Can you be just plain...
Whelmed?
This is going to...
Okay, hold on.
Uh...
Okay, we gotta get the mouse down there, alright?
Oh, wait!
I can't reach it!
Oh, no!
Wait...
Oh, here, from here.
Boink!
Is she gonna notice the mouse here?
Oh!
Oh my god!
Oh, I missed it!
Okay, wait.
I have to get him down there.
I get it now.
I get it.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
I get it now.
I get it.
Let's wait here.
Because he lands by the book.
Mint.
I'm sorry!
I'm sorry.
Okay.
But I kind of also want to hear this.
No!
Mr. Prime Minister!
We mustn't!
If the people ever found out...
I don't care what they might think.
What do the plebeian masses understand anyway?
Certainly not our love.
Hmm...
What is the Prime Minister talking about?
I don't know!
It's your book!
I've never even heard the word plebeian before.
What is it?
AI writing it for you?
And you're just like taking it?
I wonder...
She doesn't even know!
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Tilt.
Beep.
Oh, boop.
Spin.
Pew!
And now she'll find it.
No!
What?
She didn't find it.
I like watching her typos.
Like, really.
Oh, no.
We've read it.
Okay.
Did I do it too soon?
Oh, that's fine.
I have to go through it again, though.
Okay.
Alright.
Pew!
Maybe she...
Okay, wait a second.
Maybe she has to see the rat and then I knock it onto the floor.
Right?
Maybe she sees the rat first.
There we go.
Oh, there it is.
Let's not care about the rat anymore.
Yippee!
But it's strange...
I know I left this dictionary on the shelf.
It's as if some little angel were playing naughty tricks on me.
I cannot get her accent.
She's like...
Sometimes southern, sometimes British.
Perhaps my darling angel?
Okay.
Possess.
Brush... Mama!
Turn the knob.
Where else do I go from here?
Oh my god, she's so cute!
She's so cute!
She looks like the other girl from ReZero.
It is common for writers to lose their plot to the characters.
They just steal the plot we had planned and change it.
We are weird like that.
No, Snake, we mustn't.
If Otacon ever finds out, said Ocelot, I don't care.
What does that Otaku...
No!
Wrong, Snake!
Yeah, Beatrice!
Beatrice!
What is it, my darling angel?
Ow!
My head hurts, Mama!
You poor dear.
And no wonder with a fever of 102.
Here's to a night of... wait, a night of fever.
Hotter than the love of my prime minister.
It's almost time for me to... wait, time to go out for my lesson.
Can I take the night off?
Yes, I suppose that would be best.
But wait a minute.
I bet you're happy to have an excuse to get out of it, aren't you?
Not especially.
If I ever don't want to go, I just don't go and pretend I did.
Don't reveal your secrets, Beatrice!
I go play with Camilla next door or something.
Here's to the blunt honesty of my darling angel.
Hey, today is Papa's birthday.
Oh, is it?
Don't tell her.
Yeah, what are you doing?
Aren't we going to celebrate together?
Let's not talk about your father, dear.
Dang.
What's this family drama?
Now Mama has to go back to work.
I have a deadline tonight, after all.
Okay.
Mama, wait!
Hold it.
I just have one thing to say.
Don't try and put me in the middle of you two.
Okay?
Whatever could you be talking about?
I know what's going on, you know.
You write novels and Papa wants you to stop.
But it was very selfish of you to take me and leave the house.
What is going on?
I want to go home.
Uh...
Now, now.
It's time for good little girls to go to sleep.
Especially sick little girls.
Sleeps.
I hate you, Mama!
Dang.
What is going on?
Oh yeah, we haven't checked the... what's it called?
Oh wait.
This one.
ZL.
We haven't checked this in a while.
She's still sitting there in the rain.
Hunter and the dog.
Eyebrowed villain.
Masked muscle man.
The other hitman.
The little lady.
I love it.
Valiant pet.
Perfumed lady.
Apparently she's a novelist who moved here due to a disagreement with her husband.
Nice.
Feverish firecracker.
Apparently she and Camilla are friends.
She isn't going out for her lesson tonight.
Aw, look at her.
She's so sick.
It's so sad.
And then the phone book.
Oh, it's these places.
Okay.
Cool.
Wait, a music box was hidden in the ceiling.
Big lady.
These two are quite a pair.
The father would have to be a pretty strong man to hold his own against them.
Sounds like their family circumstances are pretty complicated.
I wonder if I had a family.
When do we get to...
Oh, my lamp is out.
Wait.
Ma'am, what are you about to do with that?
Ma'am?
Ma'am, what are you about to...
What are you about to do with that?
I stopped it immediately.
I was going to look to see if there was anything else around.
But...
Wow!
She's a keeper.
Is this still too heavy?
She brought this dictionary all the way over here to look at something.
Look something up.
You did not just say, irregardless.
Is this...
I can't tell if this is on purpose or not.
Should have read the dictionary.
This is probably on purpose, right?
Here it sits all alone.
Either she forgot what she wanted to look up.
Or she forgot she even wanted to look anything up in the first place.
Hmm.
Is irregardless really a word?
Okay.
My darling lady.
Oh, my darling lady.
To think that you were a spy all along.
What?
What are you going to do to me, Mr. Prime Minister?
I will arrest you and make sure you receive the proper penalty.
You're sentenced to be imprisoned in my cell of love.
And punished with my whip of passion.
Ooh la la.
Oh, Mr. Prime Minister.
Oh, my dear lady.
I would totally listen to an audiobook of this.
Hmm.
I'd hate to live in this Prime Minister's country.
When...
It's still too far away for me to reach.
Everything is still too far.
I have to do something when...
We turn the knob, right?
It's right up your alley.
It actually is.
Um...
Hmm...
I forgot about your harlequin novel hobby.
Is that...
Isn't a harlequin novel like...
Um...
An actual brand?
The only thing I can think of doing is turning off the light.
What is going on?
Oh, she made a typo.
Ah!
Okay.
Got it.
We have to wait for her to make a typo.
Clearly.
Oh, I just want to watch this again, though.
Whoo!
She is one...
Spicy mama.
Hot meatball!
Yeah!
Uh...
I guess I'll turn it off again.
Oh!
Okay, now she makes the typo.
There we go.
Pew!
Oh!
Oh, we're so close!
Okay, now we have to wait.
Wait.
How do we get her to make another typo?
Um...
Wait.
Uh...
Um...
Oh!
Pew!
There we go.
Oh, wait.
I wanted to do the other one, though.
I wanted to do the clock, but that's okay.
So Also, Yen-Rui...
I see you don't know.
Love the flour-haired lady's voice.
No!
Is this the Prime Minister!
If you're Received!
Does that voice belong to Mistress Mint?
So true!
Who's saying this?
Hello?
Is that you?
Oh.
How many times are you going to make me tell you?
Tonight is that holiest of all nights!
Please, I'm begging you.
Change your mind and come home to me.
I think you're the one who needs to change his mind.
Please, put yourself in my position.
You can write your novel just as well from home.
Until you change your mind, your daughter and I won't be coming home.
Even if that means forever!
Forever!
Let me talk to Amelie.
Her name is Amelie.
At least...
You can't talk to her.
She's sick with a fever right now.
And I won't have you giving her nightmares.
I want to talk to Papa!
Now, I don't want to hear your voice anymore tonight.
Please, wait a minute.
Don't try to call again.
I won't answer.
I refuse to answer!
I love them.
They're so dramatic.
Wow, we get to go to...
Trouble...
Yay, Trouble...
Trouble Man's apartment.
Oh, whoops.
I didn't mean to press that.
You voice her so well, Mint.
Thank you.
Oh, we can't even reach her though.
I'm curious about what's up there though.
Oh no!
Okay, we just have to leave then.
After all.
Look at her being like a lump in there.
Trouble...
Yeah, we still can't reach it.
Okay, let's leave.
Dialing to Trouble Man's office.
I'm a one man show.
I can voice everybody in this game.
Oh!
Are you alright sir?
I ordered all of you not to come near me.
Ow!
One of my favorite emotes is the dancing lady emote.
Because her legs are all kicked up.
And she's all like, Yippee!
And he looks just like the dancing lady emote.
Oh my gosh, it's so good!
Yes!
The dancing lady!
It's my favorite on Twitter, I think.
She looks the best on Twitter.
But look at her, she's so yippee!
Yes, sir!
Hoo!
Ole!
Oh bother!
Another strange room and another strange person.
I wish these telephone lines came with nameplates or something.
Sheesh!
Alright, let's trick around.
Let's see what we got.
Documents, medicine, bottle...
Water pitcher, flap the flag...
Whoop!
Uh, flap!
No, I still can't reach.
Huh.
Is there anything else in here?
Oh wow!
Whoa, this room is huge!
There's a big old melon!
Oh my god, it must remind him of her!
Aww...
And the door is open.
Uh oh.
What is with these people?
Not leaving their...
Not locking their doors.
Contraption to do the fan.
Is there anything up in the ceiling?
No.
Don't say melon.
You need to leave!
Oh!
My bad.
How am I supposed to...
I still can't reach!
Hmm.
Gonzalo!
That feels like as far as I can get.
Probably involves the fan, which means there's another way to get to it, but I've...
There's nothing else that I can...
I can't...
Possess!
Hmm...
Thanks in the way!
I mean, there's nothing I can possess and do something with, you know?
Maybe I can't do anything yet...
Here.
Maybe I have to wait.
Like can I...
If I go back to this lady's apartment...
What if I go back to the junkyard?
Sorry, is she still there?
No, she said she was going to the restaurant, right?
Visit missile, I miss him.
Miu Miu, thank you!
I love you so much.
Thank you!
Not much time has passed since I was here last, but the situation has changed.
Whoa!
Who are these?
Looks like they're examining my body.
I wonder who they are.
Oh my gosh!
Phoenix pre-spike!
And the other... oh my god!
Dancing Pixar.
Besides them, a certain somebody else wriggles and bounces happily.
I wonder who that person really is too.
It's Feeny!
Welcome back!
You weren't gone very long.
What's going on here?
The police are here to start the criminal investigation.
You know, into your murder.
The guy in the green suit looks like the other prosecutor.
The really wimpy guy who always gets his hair blown off.
John, attorney name Ace.
You know, into your murder?
My murder case, eh?
Where is Lin?
Is she alright?
So you found out her name already, did you?
I'm impressed.
Excuse me!
Smad scientist.
Sounded like she was in some sort of... some kind of immediate danger.
Where is Gumshoe?
So true, I missed that guy.
Mr. Payne!
Yes, that's the other attorney at... or sorry, prosecutor.
Yes, yes.
Not to mention the fact that Hitman is after her again.
I'm eating again.
I am once again taking a bite of chicken.
Oh, um...
You don't have to worry about that kind of thing.
What?
She was just taken into custody a few minutes ago.
C-c-c-custody?
You mean she was arrested?
But why?
I feel bad because your chicken is probably cold by now.
It is, but that's okay.
I'll eat anything.
I'm a hungry ghost.
I don't know.
I'm just a desk lamp.
Shut up!
No, you're not!
I better see what I can find out.
Trick time.
Doesn't he look like Payne?
Traffical.
Ultra.
My body.
Sizzle.
Bag.
What do you say in here?
Quite a thing, huh?
This case.
Yes!
I'm one of our own!
A murderer!
Heads will roll over this!
One of our own?
Starting my first ever job next week!
I'm so excited.
Your streams have kept me motivated these past few weeks.
So thank you so much!
Thank you!
So lucky!
Congratulations!
Congrats!
I hope you have fun!
Fake Phoenix and fake Payne.
She's a rookie too.
Wait, so she is with them?
Oh, I heard she was carrying out some crazy investigation.
Rookies aren't given craziest timings like that!
Not even rookies like Lin!
I can't.
Oh god.
I can't do it.
I can't do it!
Oh, I can't do it!
Yeah, but I heard she was... special.
She's got strong ties to Inspector Cabanela of the Special Investigation Unit.
I plan on moving up the ladder on my own merits myself, okay?
Just jealous that she's better than you?
It's because the chicken I'm eating has a tiny bit of spice.
So when I use my throat in that way...
My... I... what's the word?
I get the spice all in my throat.
Also, I just noticed that the doctor is blue.
I think he's not on our side.
I think he's with the bad guys.
Uh-oh.
Or he's a zombie.
I don't know.
Whoa.
Wait, detective!
Shouldn't be standing around gossiping.
Never know who might be listening.
Like me.
Like me?
Oh god, he looks like a zombie for real!
What?
I think we can safely assume the cause of death was the bullet he took in the chest.
Bring the stretcher.
I'll look into the rest back at the lab.
He's so... he looks so scary.
Would you mind waiting here for a bit, doctor?
Inspector Cabanella, head of the Special Investigation Unit, is on his way now.
They have to say his full title.
Dr. Luigi.
If it has spice, why don't you just dunk the chicken in milk?
So true.
Thanks for the super chat!
Special Investigation Unit?
Why?
What do they want with a case like this?
Sorry, he has a big mustache, so he's probably got a refined voice.
I don't know.
But Cabanella's our top investigator.
We don't want him... want to get him all bent out of shape, or there'll be hell to pay.
I don't see what that has to do with me.
So true, doctor.
I don't really get what Cabanella wants to come for either.
It's probably just a big lark for him, but it makes things tougher on us.
Hey, watch what you say behind his back.
Never know who might be listening.
Like me.
And me.
Is that him?
Woah, he's...
He's kind of awesome.
Wow!
The tension of a crime scene.
Oh!
Yeah!
Nothing like it, baby!
He's Elvis!
Oh my god!
Woah!
Oh my god, he's so smooth, boss!
Oh, wow!
Woah!
Evenin', boys.
How's it looking?
Inspector Cabanella!
Thank you for coming.
Allow me to report, sir.
Fine, fine.
You just gotta hold that thought.
I'm gonna make a little phone call first.
I was gonna...
Oh my god, I stopped.
I was literally about to say, I'm surprised he didn't spin around when picking up the phone first, but he picked up the phone and spun afterwards!
So this is the head of the Special Investigation Unit.
He seems... unique?
Unique?
Trick time!
Alright, let's... who is he talking to?
Look at them.
Here he is for his big lark.
Aren't you going to confront him about it?
About what?
I'm going to make my report!
Yeah, that's about what I figured.
You have no spine!
You have no spine.
Come on.
Deal me the deal.
How's it going over there, baby?
Going?
How is it going, you ask?
You'd like to know how it's going?
I would say it's going well enough.
About fair to average, if I had to say.
Yes, it's going alright!
The star child?
Not the man I was hoping to talk to there, baby.
Do me a favor and put that other nice man on the horn now, would you?
That's a nice fellow.
If it had anything to do with this park, I'm the one to talk to.
I'm the guardian of this park.
Yes!
Who is this?
They do kind of look like Lottie.
Oh!
Get out of here!
Sorry about that, Inspector.
I just got here.
Well, glad to hear you made it.
That other fellow just about threw me for a loop.
Yeah, a lot of harp.
Yeah, yeah.
Started blathering something about being the guardian of the park or some such.
Yes, him.
Sorry about that.
Well, start doing your staking out.
Well, start doing your staking out thing, baby.
And buzz me if anything comes up.
Yes, sir.
Trace complete.
We're going to the park.
Park.
Now then, sir.
If I make my...
If I...
If I make...
If I may make my report, sir.
Doc Yoohoo.
Oh, Doc.
Talking to me?
I need you to handle this case with your finest care and attention.
Would you do that for me, Doc?
That guy stutters a lot.
Yeah, he does.
What a loser with a stutter.
Don't need you to tell me how to do my job.
I like the doctor.
Anyhoo, I'd like to see the suspect now, if I may.
I'm sorry, sir.
I asked her to let herself be taken into custody voluntarily, sir.
She's being detained in the Junkyard Super Attendant's Office right now.
Super's Office, eh?
Super.
And where's that?
Yeah, what a loser.
Yeah.
Wait, stop stuttering, Bozo.
Just beyond my limit.
Somewhere you parked your bicycle, Inspector.
Where?
Oh, they lowered the drawbridge.
I'll go interview the suspect then.
Yeah, nothing like it, baby.
Wait, I need to go follow him.
Oh, oh.
Carry on, boys.
Good luck, sir.
Look at him go.
Even up the stairs.
He's so cool.
Trick time.
That Inspector Cabanela, he sure has a strange air about him.
You can say that again.
And I've never seen anybody use stairs the way he does.
I hear he is dancing his way up the stairs of promotion that same airy way.
He's like the Joker.
And I hear Lin is his personal favorite.
What's the deal between those two?
Hey, now should I know.
How do I get up there anyway?
Traffic sign.
Traffic cone.
Umbrella.
I guess maybe we go to the park instead.
Right?
Let's just check it out.
We live in a society.
It appears to be the entrance to a nearly deserted, dimly lit park.
The voices of two young people drift over to me on the breeze.
What is going on?
Stop the park from being turned into a housing site.
Protect the park.
The rock of the gods.
Sorry, but could you do that somewhere else?
I'm a little busy right now.
I don't have time to talk.
I suppose you think I'm a man of dubious character.
A questionable person.
No, I...
But if an objective person were asked, they might think you were a little suspicious yourself.
So true.
How does he get his hair like that?
As two suspicious people.
Two suspicious characters.
Shouldn't we take the time to converse with each other?
That's one way to put it, pal.
Oh boy.
All right.
Just for a minute.
Hope you have a great stream today.
Min just came home.
Welcome home.
Welcome home, Nine.
Thank you.
There.
I like your attitude.
I like it very much.
Let's relax and talk a while then.
The night is young.
And so are we.
Oh man.
Is he flirting or...
I don't really know.
We have this leaflet.
Oh, we can't literally go anywhere else.
Oh no.
Back
to the junkyard, I suppose.
Couple dead ends.
Yeah.
I was trying to get tired too.
So might end soon-ish.
I wanted to end if we like saved one more person because it kind of like gave us that save.
But...
Oh, what's the dog saying?
Oh.
I think we can safely...
Pretty safely assume that this was the murder weapon.
They found the murder weapon.
Can you not use the lamp?
It's not moving.
Oh no.
That pistol.
Is it hers?
Is it Lin's?
Oh no.
Same model as the pistols you detectives carry around.
You don't think it's Lin's, do you?
Unless I'm a detective.
No.
I'm Lupin.
Lupin...
Lupin's cousin.
This is not good.
If it is hers, it's Jover.
So Lin is a detective and the murder weapon might be her pistol.
What could it all mean?
Trick time.
Yeah.
See, I can't reach the lamp and it's not moving anymore.
This is the weapon that took my life.
A pistol, eh?
My memory seems to be hazy on pistols.
But I have seen them before.
That's for sure.
Let's see.
This part right here is...
Oh!
If you want to fire the thing, aim it in your own direction.
.
Lupin the 3.5.
Groupon the 3rd.
I didn't fire it.
I'm the victim here.
This is the act of somebody who's jealous of my abilities as a detective.
Well, what are you glaring at me for?
I'm hardly jealous of you.
Well, guess that proves it's a real gun.
Sheesh.
What was that?
Is that what I think it was?
The sound of a gun.
I've got a bad feeling about this.
Every time that phone rings, it's bad news.
It's like that old riddle.
Which came first?
The ringing of the phone or the crime case?
Classic.
Classic saying.
If you say so.
Uh-oh.
Doctor's like, anyway.
That was...
That sounded bad.
Um, anyway.
Oh!
Ah, there you are.
Do me a favor and have the doc come to you.
To the super's office, would you?
Uh, he seems pretty busy at the moment, sir.
Which one of you...
Which one are you?
The green one or the blue one?
I'm the green one, sir.
Listen, greenie.
Get the good doc over here this instant.
Or I'll see it.
You'll never wear a green suit again.
Oh!
You'll only be wearing black and white stripes.
In the slammer.
Yes, sir.
I'll send him up right, sir.
We're going to the super's office.
Here he goes.
Please, doctor.
Go to the superintendent's office immediately.
If I must.
There he goes.
Shuffling away.
No one cares about my body.
What's going on?
Don't ask me, but something seems really, really wrong.
That shot sounded like it was coming from somewhere around the maintenance building.
Okay.
Uh, dial.
To the super's office.
Who died?
Oh my god, wait.
There might be someone that actually died.
Yet another gunshot rings out in the lonely junkyard on the edge of town.
The sound gives me the feeling a new death will be waiting on the other side of the line.
It better not be her again.
Apparently, I'm not the only one the Reaper's interested in tonight.
But as long as there's anything I can do about it, I don't plan on letting anyone else die.
Is it Lynn?
I don't know.
I hope not.
Lynn?
Are you alive?
Are you good?
Oh, we cleared it!
Nice!
Um...
What a funny illustration.
It's just... it's just the laugh.
Riko, thanks for the 20 gifted!
Thank you!
Yes.
Okay, good.
We got the save.
I am kind of curious to see, though, who died.
So we'll see, and then I'll end it here.
Chapter 4.
How many chapters are there, actually?
I have no idea.
Changing a person's fate is no easy task.
Especially when their fate is death.
The scene at the other end of the line is pretty much what I expected.
All except for one thing.
Oh, that is her.
No!
Lynn!
Hang in there, baby!
What?
It looks like some piece of trash shot her from the top of the pile of garbage outside!
Here, let me take a look at her.
Maybe there's something I...
Sorry, can't allow that, Pigeon Man.
I investigate, and you superintend.
You have your job, and I have mine.
I feel like they keep killing off Lynn so that we can't get more information out of her.
So that more things are mysterious.
She seems like the type that would, like, info dump, you know?
And, like, kind of explain things to us out loud.
Let's leave each other to his own profession, shall we?
Yeah, well, here's what I think.
How much of a pro can you be if you let her get shot right in front of you?
Anyway, have it your way.
I'll stay out of your hair.
We got the mad scientist with his little... little pigeon.
So cute.
Oh!
Where did the... did the bird drop it?
So cute.
Bird.
What?
He's so awesome.
That was so smooth.
That's not how... okay.
Everything's so goofy.
What took you so long?
Quit dragging your feet.
Who are you to shout at me?
Now let me have a look at the victim.
I haven't even looked yet, but I can already tell you she's dead.
Her second death of the night, actually.
Yo, she's... it's like... it's like Final Destination.
You're fated to die.
Yeah, I'm getting kind of eepy.
We are going to... stop here.
So I'm gonna say... oh, whoops.
Nope.
There we go.
I'm going to save.
Yes.
And, um, we shall continue this next time.
Um, sometime next week.
Yes, yes, yes.
Sounds good.
Uh, continue playing.
No.
I'm sleepy.
Oh, 15 chapters left?
So it's 20?
What?
20 chapters?
I know that it said, like, how long to beat.
It said about...
Uh, 20 hours?
Oh, not 20.
Sorry, 12 hours.
Um, but with, like, reading and talking and everything, you can kind of...
extend that a little bit longer.
Maybe.
Um, but we'll see.
18?
18 hours or 18 chapters?
Weird logarithm.
Thank you for the five.
Get it!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
But, uh, it's a ride.
I'm excited.
12 hours sounds canon.
There's 14 left, so there's still a long run.
Yeah.
I'm excited.
I'm already so invested.
Thanks for the stream.
This is one of my favorite games.
It's so cool seeing you play it.
Yeah!
I won it!
I've been wanting to play it a really long time.
And, uh, my friend, she recommended it, so I was like, well...
I mean, I'm a ghost, so now's the perfect time to play it.
Favorite character so far?
Missile.
I like Missile.
I like, actually, the fanfiction lady, too.
But, uh...
Today's my birthday, but the only thing I got gifted was a written exam!
Can I ask her happy birthday?
Of course, Tripp Tripp!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Tripp Tripp.
Happy birthday!
Missile cute.
Missile so cute.
Thanks for the stream, Mint.
You did some great voices.
It was fun to listen to while I worked.
I tried to because, like, what if you're not looking and you're like, who's talking, you know?
I saw people finishing four to five streams.
Okay, that's totally doable then.
It's totally doable.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna try and finish before, because, um...
In the next, in the upcoming weeks, I'm gonna be, uh...
Going out of town, um...
Oh, well, no.
I keep thinking I'm going out of town for one weekend, but I'm not.
But I am going out of town, and then before I know it, I'll be going to Japan, so...
So much going on already.
But tomorrow, I'll be collabing with, um...
Haruka, Matara, and Henya again.
We're playing Left 4 Dead.
Oh!
I gotta, I gotta get some... I gotta get some of the...
Some of the models and stuff.
I gotta get some of the models.
Um, and the, the download stuffs.
Yeah, get them mods.
Yeah!
Wowza!
I ghost tricked back in time to send this!
Woohoo!
Thanks for unwrapping!
This game is a legendary puzzle game.
Might consider picking it up again while it's on sale too.
Thanks for the stream.
Yeah!
I got it on sale, actually, for the Switch.
It is on sale.
Um...
It was like $10 off, so it was really awesome.
I was like, yahoo!
Yippee!
I tried calling you on my Ouija board.
But all it said was...
Gronsaker.
What's that?
Turns out I accidentally used my Norwegian...
...board instead.
Classic mistake, honestly.
Never seen this big game before, but man, it's so fun.
Can't wait to see where this goes.
Thanks, AKS!
Thank you!
Vegetables?
It means vegetables.
Eat your...
Uh...
Gronsakers, everybody.
Collab's gonna be so much fun.
Yeah!
I'm so excited!
So...
Mmm!
Um...
Yes.
Uh...
Thank you guys for hanging out with me today!
Thank you so much!
Merlin, thank you!
Thanks for the ghostly trickiest stream!
Just curious, since you're a ghost...
If you have any famous ghost role models like...
Casper, Beetlejuice...
Yuyuko Saikyo...
Koji...
Um...
To be fair, Ace Combat 7 is also on sale.
I think a lot of games are on sale right now because of Golden Week, so...
Might wanna grab some stuff.
Japanese games in particular, you know?
I really enjoyed the stream today.
Thanks, AKS!
Thank you!
Sorry, is it okay if I shorten your name to that?
Or should I...
Should I...
Should I keep saying the full name, you know?
Um...
Yeah.
Uh...
At least call him Mike Dyson.
Um...
I feel like I was gonna say something else, but I can't remember.
Oh, tomorrow I have...
But yeah, tomorrow I have the collab.
And then Saturday, I have a, um...
I'm part of a, um...
A karaoke relay...
Um...
With a bunch of other VTubers.
So...
The waiting rooms for both streams are already up.
Um...
Yes...
I'm...
Ah...
After hearing about you wanting to be a marine biologist and liking sea conservation from the podcast, I want to recommend the Aqua Taupe on White Sand.
I've seen Aqua Taupe!
And actually, the opening is done by my...
One of my favorite idol groups, Arcana Project.
Yeah...
I didn't think I'd be able to continue my membership.
Oh, thanks, Shady Raven!
Thank you!
Appreciate it.
Japanese games on sale, but no Nekopara on sale.
That's cool!
Hi, man!
I got my wisdom teeth taken out this morning, and after I woke up, I just rambled on about how much I love you.
I know!
I got a video of it!
Thank you.
I love you too.
Mwah!
That's so strong.
That's so awesome.
It's all on video!
I watched it!
Like, three times!
Your voiceover work for the characters was so on point.
It was a ton of fun watching you play.
Thank you so much!
I love doing voices in games like this.
But it does make me tired out a little bit more.
But I do...
I've been taking a lot of throat medicine lately, and I do feel like my throat has been healing, so I'm very, very relieved.
I'm very happy about that.
But I take it like three times a day.
It's like a Chinese herbal medicine thing, so...
That a lot of...
First...
Actually, it was Ayami-sensei that gifted it to me.
And...
So I tried it...
When she gifted it to me first, and then I ordered some more.
So...
Yeah!
I'm so...
I'm so relieved.
Three times a day?
So much.
I...
I take it...
I take it in the morning, and then I take it before stream, and then I take it after stream.
So...
Um...
Is it...
Yes!
Koa, kao...
Koa, koa...
It is that!
It's so great!
It works so well!
My, my cute!
You're so cute!
Oh my gosh...
But yeah, it's super duper.
It is the good stuff.
It seriously works so well.
We love Ayami.
I know!
I love her so much!
She has the most amazing smile.
She has the most amazing smile in the world.
The smile is...
It's actually really delicious.
It is!
It's delicious and it works.
They have bubble tea flavors with it in Asia?
Seriously?
It's very reliable.
You can even make it a tea.
Yeah!
I have seen that.
But I just take it by the spoonful.
But it has been helping so much.
So I'm very very grateful that she introduced it to me.
She's going to Chicago.
I know!
I'm so happy for her!
I think it's her first time going to a convention.
In Singapore we got the bubble tea with it.
Really?
Maybe I can import it.
Maybe.
But yeah.
Anyways.
I'm feeling good about that because I was so worried about my throat for a while.
But it's been helping!
You're so close to 200k.
I know!
Wait.
Where am I at?
I don't even know.
I think I'm still at...
Wait.
I was at...
190...
197!
Close.
We'll see.
So close.
Woo!
Woohoo!
Anyways.
Ansumito, everybody!
I'm going to go sleep now.
I'm actually going to finish my dinner and then I'm going to sleep.
And I'll see you guys tomorrow for the collab.
And Saturday for karaoke.
And Sunday.
And I don't think I'm streaming one day.
I don't think I'm streaming one day.
I'll actually have a schedule for next week since it's...
Oh wait.
When is Matara coming?
No.
Wait.
Actually, I don't think Matara is coming anymore.
I don't know.
I'm going to ask her.
Anyway.
Ansumito!
Bye bye!
Thank you guys!
We'll play more ghost trick in a couple of days.
Yeah.
Next week.
I might even do like a couple of ghost tricks in a row or something.
Because I'm having a lot of fun with it.
So...
Ansumito!
But I do kind of need to rest my voice because it's a lot of talking.
We'll figure it out.
Okay.
Bye bye!
Have a good night!
Or, if it's morning, have a good day!
Ansumito!
Have a good day!
Bye bye!
Ansumentos!
Thank you!
Bye bye!